bien mes chers
collègues nous reprenons nos
travaux et nous allons commencer cet
après-midi les travaux relatifs au
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 en
auditionnant les ministres que je
remercie d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation comme de coutume cette
audition sera l'occasion d'une
discussion générale du projet de loi
nous en viendrons la semaine prochaine à
la discussion sur les articles du mardi
après-midi au jeudi
après-midi nous constatons de nouveau
cette année les effets bénéfiques de la
réforme LOLF SS adoptée en 2022 puisque
cela nous permet d'examiner plus
longuement le texte avant le
l'expiration du délai de dépôt des
amendements le texte a été déposé sur le
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale le 27
septembre et le délai expire ce vendredi
à
13h avant de passer la parole au
ministre je vous rappelle le déroulement
de cette audition qui sera identique aux
règles des années
précédentes après l'intervention des
ministres et Madame berger nous
rejoindra d'ailleurs je donnerai la
parole à la rapporteur générale pour 3
minutes au rapporteur thématique pour 2
minutes puis aux orateurs de groupe pour
4 minutes et au rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des finances pour 2
minutes des autres collègues pourront
ensuite poser des questions
complémentaires nous pouvons dépasser 2
minutes je vais donc passer la parole à
messieurs les ministres monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau et Thomas casazenav et
comme je le disais madame berger nous
rejoint incessamment sous peu je vous en
prie messieur
bienvenue eu madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chargé comptes
publics cher Thomas casdav madame la
rapporteur générale madames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs thématiques mesdames et
messieurs les députés je suis honoré de
vous retrouver aujourd'hui pour cet
exercice incournable de la séquence
budgétaire autonnale qui est l'audition
des ministres en charge des comptes
sociaux par votre commission euh
audition qui se déroule évidemment dans
un contexte global dont
personne ici n'est ignorant que ce soit
évidemment pour dire immédiatement les
termes les tensions
hospitalières pression et la difficulté
pour nos concitoyens de dans l'accès aux
soins euh l'hétérogénéité de cet accès
aux soins suivant dans les différents
territoires de la République la
mobilisation aussi ce vendredi de de la
médecine libérale et en même temps des
éléments plus positifs notamment avec
des campagnes de recrutement à l'hôpital
qui
sont les plus positifs depuis une
dizaine d'années et aussi une reprise de
l'activité euh hospitalière donc un un
contexte contrasté mais mais mais
évidemment tendu et difficile
euh l'exercice d'aujourd'hui est
d'autant plus essentiel qu'il va nous
permettre évidemment d'entrer dans le
plus en détail dans le texte attendu et
nous conduire à évoquer une partie des
des sujets les plus importants de notre
protection sociale et de la santé en
particulier je salue aussi les les les
membres des différents groupes qui ont
bien voulu participer à nos côtés avec
les différents ministres sociaux et
Thomas casaznav à ce que aux entretien
que nous avons que nous avons eu
euh autour au ministère dans les le
bâtiment des ministères sociaux ce
furent des entretiens que j'ai trouvé
pour ma part utiles même si euh et je le
redis ici euh cette ces espaces de
discussion sont très précieux même si
c'est entre ces murs dans l'hémicycle à
quelques mètres de nous que la loi sera
adoptée et la seule et que les débats
les plus politiques peuvent peuvent
évidemment avoir lieu et avoir une
portée et évidemment le contenu des loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale il
est bien
plus année après année on a bien plus à
faire qu' un qu' un simple exercice
budgétaire on est dans un des
rendez-vous politiques les plus
essentiels même pas même s'il n'est pas
forcément les plus lisibles pour nos
compatriotes qui permet de mesurer le
chemin parcouru et j'allais dire à très
court terme aussi parce qu'il y a des
questions sur l'atterrissage
2023 mais aussi de présenter le cap que
le le gouvernement propose aujourd'hui
au Parlement c'est un texte qui est
évidemment indissociable d'une de son
contexte de moyen terme ce que j'entends
par là c'est que les derniers exercices
ont non notamment porter des moyens
inédits pour protéger notre pays nos
concitoyens et notre système de santé
tout au long de la crise du covid mais
aussi pour pour opérer les
revalorisations indispensables des
personnels soignants et leur pouvoir
d'achat face aux effets de
l'inflation aujourd'hui le contexte est
toujours celui d'une inflation
importante mais aussi celui d'une
trajectoire financière de la sécurité
sociale qui est si sans sans employer
des termes grandil lo qui est dégradé
avec deux branches particulièrement
déficitaires que sont la maladie et la
vieillesse je laisserai bien sûr à
Thomas CASNAV le soin de le préciser
plus avant mais je ne peux évidemment
pour ma part m'empêcher me tenir à
distance de cette question du déficite
et notamment de la branche maladie
certes celui-ci s'est résorbé en partie
puisque nous étions à - 21 milliards en
22 et nous serons à - 9 et demi en 23
c'est une une mode nouvelle mais nous
mesurons aussi tout le chemin à
parcourir encore pour revenir à
l'équilibre l'équilibre n'est pas une
fin en soi l'équilibre et la
soutenabilité pour ma part je la
considère comme la condition de
pérennité de ce système assurantiel
protecteur et universel public qu'il
nous incombe de protéger pour le
transmettre aux générations à venir en
même temps si j'ai mentionné ces
éléments en premier je je je je je dois
dire simultanément que ce cap qui est
indispensable celui de la soutenabilité
nous ne pouvons pas le prendre sans
prendre le risque d'amoindrir nos
efforts de soutien au public que nous
que nous devons accompagner ni en
prenant le risque de repousser des
mesures d'investissement indispensable à
la consolidation et à la modernisation
de notre système de santé c'est donc un
PLFSS qui vise à la fois d'une part à
poursuivre l'investissement et la
transformation du système de santé avec
une priorité donnée à l'accès aux soins
et aux produits de santé à la à la
valorisation de langage n des soignants
et au virage de la prévention et d'autre
part à renforcer la pertinence des
dépenses et la responsabilité de tous
les acteurs face à la croissance des
dépenses de santé avec des économies et
des recettes permettant également
d'améliorer l'efficience du système au
final et on aura l'occasion sans doute
d'en d'en discuter quand j'entends
certains évoquer des économies nous
avons évidemment un PLFSS qui augmente
de par rapport à l'année précédente et
les économies que nous envisageons de
faire ce sont des économies à faire sur
un tendentiel de dépenses mais ce double
engagement que j'évoqué l'ame il se
traduit par une progression de longam de
+ 3,2 % hors dépenses lié à la crise
sanitaire soit une augmentation et je me
permet de le redire qui est supérieure à
l'inflation prévisionnelle puisque cette
inflation est et Thomas le dira mieux
que moi estimé à 2,5 % hors tabac euh
donc oui nous aurons à faire des efforts
et de la maîtrise de la croissance de la
dépense sur le tendentiel et par
ailleurs je je je considère pour ma part
qu'il y a un un enjeu démocratique et je
je ne me paye pas de mot aussi à
présenter devant le Parlement un budget
qui fera l'objet éventuellement de
révision mais de révision qui
ne peuvent pas avoir en tout état de
cause l'ampleur de celle qu'on a connu
pendant toute la période du covid ou
pendant la période de inflationniste
maximal puisque'à la fin on vote un
objectif de dépense donc qui n'est pas
la notre ligne et que et que nous savons
pouvoir auquel nous savons pouvoir
déroger donc cette évolution
globale s'applique à un N d'AM pour 23 à
partir d'un d'un Nam 23
qui lui-même est revu à la hausse de 2,8
milliards d'euros pour intégrer les
revalorisations salariales et la
dynamique des soins de ville donc c'est
bien en base on repart avec 2,8
milliards d'euros de plus que ceux que
vous avez été amené à vous serez amené à
voter sur ce projet et sur cette
rectification je veux évidemment laisser
le plus de temps possible aux échanges
mais je souhaite rapidement développer
euh très rapidement quelques quelques
grands objectifs
d'abord ce ce PLFSS doit nous
permettre de de de d'accélérer le virage
de la prévention alors cette formule
vous pour pour ceux d'entre vous qui
sont élu depuis plusieurs mandats vous
avez dû l'entendre à de très nombreuses
reprises je j'entends pour ma part et je
crois que la la la les éléments sont
inscrits dans ce projet de loi conduire
une véritable politique de prévention
adossé à ce qui qui s'appelle un
changement ou une bataille culturelle
qui doit concerter concerner chacun
d'entre nous dès le plus jeune âge c'est
à ce titre que vous trouverez dans le
projet doit de financement de la
sécurité sociale le financement de
plusieurs mesures et campagne de santé
publique je pense notamment à la grande
compagne campagne de vaccination contre
les infections liées au papiom virirus
100 % de prise en charge dans tous les
collèges pour les élèves de 5e et dont
les injections ont déjà débutter tout
comme une mesure et alors là je ne vais
pas m'abariter derrière mon accent du
midi la gratuité des préservatifs pour
les moins de 26 ans où la prise en
charge des protections menstruelles
réutilisables pour les jeunes femmes et
les plusécaires et je me permets de de
de de d'évoquer ces deux points parce
que on a pu considérer un moment que ces
deux éléments étaient des des gadgets
quand on voit le recours massif à ces
deux mesures on comprend qu'il ne s'agit
pas du tout de mesures qui étaient en en
fait accessoire la prévention c'est
également un enjeu majeur dans d'autres
chantiers santé des femme santé mentale
lutte contre les addictions et le tabac
avec la présentation prochaine du
programme national de lutte contre le
tabac et par ailleurs il me semble
important de démontrer et ce PLFSS le
permettra mais aussi la mobilisation de
crédit par exemple de de France 2030 que
l'investissement dans la la prévention
n'est pas un investissement uniquement
de moyen terme ou de long terme je pense
notamment mais peut-être qui
reviendronsnous vous le certains
parlementaires l'ont évoqué lors des
précédentes ENF question au gouvernement
la semaine dernière que le la mise à
disposition d'un traitement
d'immunisation contre la bronchiollyite
qui est un investissement permettra
derrière aussi au-delà de la santé de
nos plus jeunes compatriotes des
économies en terme d'hospitalisation euh
dans la lignée dans dans dans au-delà de
la
prévention nous avons souhaité dans la
lignée des avancées en mailleur en
faveur d'un meilleur partage des
compétences et d'un accès plus direct
aux professionnels dans un système de
santé au fonctionnement modernisé grâce
notamment à la proposition de loi portée
par Stéphanie Rist nous poursuivons dans
ce texte avec un élargissement des
compétences des pharmaciens en matière
de prescription d'antibiotiques après la
réalisation d'un test rapide
d'orientation diagnostic pour les
angines et les cystites je rappelle les
chiffres parce qu'ils sont peut-être ils
donnent quelques ordre de grandeur c'est
6 millions de consultations chez le
médecin chaque année pour une angine et
3 millions pour une cystite donc c'est
quelque chose d'évidemment central c'est
une c'est une mesure qui va dans le même
sens que tout le travail déjà réalisé
autour de l'élargissement des
compétences vaccinal notamment des
pharmaciens pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins grâce à des professionnels de prox
proximité qui représente bien souvent la
porte d'entrée dans le système de santé
et c'était toute la philosophie du
projet de loi de la proposition de loi
présentée par par la rapporteur générale
moderniser notre système de santé pour
améliorer l'accès aux soins c'est aussi
s'appuyer sur des expérimentations et
des initiatives développées localement
ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale prévoit la création
alors au-delà du jargon d'un forfait
pluséacteur permettant de financer des
équipes de soins dans une logique de
généralisation de certaines
expérimentations issues du dispositif de
l'article 51 en gros beaucoup de de
maisons de santé pluriprofessionnell qui
sont prêtes à s'engager dans un
dispositif de financement global et
populationnel ce qui est une bonne chose
en terme de santé publique cette mesure
permet l'entrée dans le droit commun de
dispositifs qui repose sur une logique
de parcours de coopération entre la
ville et l'hôpital et le médico-social
et d'un financement innovant et qui
permet aussi la prise en charge de
nouvelles prestations dans le cadre de
forfait tel par exemple que l'activité
physique
adaptée je voudrais souligner très
rapidement que ce PLFSS comporte aussi
une mesure majeure sur la réforme du
financement des établissements de santé
presque 20 ans après l'entrée en vigueur
de la T2A ces effets ces effets positifs
comme ses limites sont largement
documentés et ont conduit vous le savez
avit depuis 2017 à mettre en œuvre une
stratégie de diversification des
financements aujourd'hui dans ce PLFSS
nous vous proposons autour de trois
briques une réforme globale et de long
terme mettant fin au caractère central
de la T2A faisant place à une part
structurante de la rémunération sur des
objectifs de santé publique négocié à
l'échelle d'un territoire et permettant
une rémunération effective des mission
réalisé par
chacun finalement l'accès aux soins
c'est une attention toujours plus grand
enfin je dire enfin l'accès aux soins
c'est une attention toujours plus grande
portée au plus précaire et à la justice
sociale le texte prévoit aussi une
meilleure articulation de la de la
complémentaire santé solidaire avec
certains minimas sociaux dont la
loocation adules handicapé permettant à
nos concitoyens les plus fragiles
d'accéder plus facilement à une
assurance maladie
complémentaire tous nos concitoyens et
vous-même évidemment premier chef êtes
préoccupé par l'enjeu relactif à l'accès
aux médicaments et aux produits de santé
c'est un sujet majeur donc le PLFSS
prévoit de compléter les outils de
gestion des tensions d'approvisionnement
et des situations de pénurie que nous
connaissons malheureusement depuis
plusieurs années en France comme dans la
plupart des pays européens c'est le cas
notamment même si ça n'est pas la mesure
la plus structurante de la dispensation
de la dispensation à l'unité ou encore
de la limitation des prescriptions par
téléconsultation en situation de tension
et de pénurie c'est d'ailleurs là aussi
une forme de prévention puisque ça a un
impact aussi très direct sur
l'antibiorésistance le plsfss prévoit
enfin des effort d'amélioration de
l'accès au médicens et actes de
diagnostic innovant sans que cela ne se
fasse au détriment de l'accès au
produits plus mature essentiel pour
soigner les Français au quotidien
deuxième grand taxe le ce projet de loi
de financement est là pour garantir la
soutenabilité de notre modèle social via
la maîtrise des dépenses et la poursuite
des investissements
euh alors il est nécessaire évidemment
de maîtriser la hausse des dépenses de
santé et d'assurer et d'assumer
certaines mesure d'économie et
d'efficience nouvelles pour permettre de
faire les investissements nécessaires au
maintien de notre modèle social les
mesures d'économie elles sont de de de
nature et toujours je me répète mais des
économies par rapport à un tendantiel de
dépenses ce sont des des des efforts
pour renforcer l'efficience et la
pertinence des soins d'une part euh et
puis de différentes actions notamment
pour renforcer les dynamiques les plus
les plus rapides qu'on constate que ce
soit par exemple sur les les les arrêts
de travail ou les médicaments qui sont à
plus de 7 % de progression cette année
ce projet de loi financement de 2024
prévoit donc par rapport au tendentiel
de progression des dépenses des
économies d'un montant de 3 milliards et
demi dans l'objectif je l'ai dit
d'assurer la soutenabilité du système et
pour permettre de financer des mesures
d'attractivité donc
cela obligera conduira à conduire des
mesures d'efficience et des mesures de
transfert de dépenses et de
responsabilisation des assurés dans les
mesures de transfert vous l'avez vu la
plus grande participation des organismes
complémentaires ou les évolutions des
tarifs journaliers de soins hospitaliers
euh et puis nous avons évidemment aussi
des économies que vous connaissez
classiquement sur les produits de santé
du fait de la baisse du prix deic et de
la maîtrise des volumes nous souhaitons
aussi veiller sans qu'on est qu'
présenté dans ce PLFSS de de mesures
hors une en particulier de de mesures
sur la pertinence des dépenses d'arrêt
maladie parce qu'on a une très forte
dynamique des dépensesindemnité
journalières observé ces dernières
années 16 milliards en 2022 contre
contre 11 milliards en 2010 qui n'est
que partiellement lié à l'amélioration
du marché de l'emploi même si c'est une
évidemment un des des facteurs
importants responsabilisation de chacun
mais stigmatisation de personnes je je
tiens à le redire puisque cela concerne
les professionnels comme les assurés ou
les employeurs complémentairement et
comme la rappel la première ministre
nous y travaillerons dans le cadre de la
conférence sociale et j'ai également
exprimer ma volonté de reprendre
rapidement le dialogue conventionnel
avec les médecins libéraux et ce sera
sans doute un des sujets les plus euh
importants ces mesures euh elles
s'inscrivent parallèlement elles elles
permettent parallèlement lesffs massifs
en faveur de celles et ceux qui
s'engagent dans les établissements de
santé médicaux-sociaux avec des moyens
très importants que nous avons déjà
déployé pour les agents pour les
soignants sans attendre l'échéance du
PLFSS les mesures Guerini pour soutenir
les agents face à l'inflation et la
hausse du point d'indice de 3,5 %. la
pérénisation et le renforcement des
mesures activité en faveur du travail de
nuit des weekends et de la permanence
des soins et tout cela à partir du socle
de rémunération déjà significativement
réhaussé grâce aux Ségur elles sont
également le reflet des revalorisations
conventionnelles conclus avec plusieurs
profession libéral de santé matérialisé
par des engagements importants et qu'on
a sans doute trop peu souligné pour
l'exercice de nouvelles missions par de
nombreux encore une fois de nombreuses
professions libérales dans le cadre d'un
exercice coordonné et au service des
plus fragiles mesdames et messieurs les
députés si je n'ai pas pu être
parfaitement exhaustif je crois avoir
adressé une vision la plus synthétique
possible des principaux enjeux dans le
champ santé et évidemment je je vous
remercie pour votre écoute et après
l'intervention de mes collègues serait à
votre totale disposition pour répondre à
vos interrogations autant que possible
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre et je peux maintenant
accueillir madame la ministre ch Aurore
qui nous arrive du Sénat et qui va
pouvoir pour poursivre la présentation
du projet de loi merci madame la
Présidente excusez-moi pour mon retard
je répondais en effet à une question
d'actualité au Sénat messieurs les
ministres madame la rapporteur général
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs et
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés jeis
très heureuse de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui pour cette première audition
parlementaire donc sur le PLFSS 2024 en
complément des discussions que nous
avons pu avoir lors des comptes de
segéure avec des représentants de chacun
de vos groupes c'est donc l'occasion de
vous présenter ici les grands axes de la
politique que je souhaite mener au
service de toutes les familles et de
continuer à coconstruire avec vous les
améliorations que nous pouvons encore
apporter à ce texte le ministère des
solidarités et des familles est bien
celui qui est au cœur des services
publics et du quotidien de nos
concitoyens parce qu'il s'agit de nos
enfants de leur prise en charge et de
leur protection de nos aînés de leur
maintien à domicile des personnes en
situation de handicap et de leur place
au cœur de notre société et parce que
évidemment toutes les les situations
sont différentes il s'agit d'apporter
une attention particulière à ce que
toutes les familles aient le plus de
choix poss possiblees dans le soutien
que notre système doit pouvoir leur
apporter à ce titre je suis heureuse que
ce projet permettent trois grandes
avancées d'abord nous renforçons le
soutien et l'accompagnement de toutes
les familles en cohérence avec ma
conception universelle de la politique
familiale qui doit nous aider à relancer
la natalité priorité absolue de l'action
de mon ministère nous faisons grandir la
branche autonomie pour relever le défi
du vieillissement de la population et
adapter surtout notre société à ce ce
défi majeur nous donnons de nouveaux
moyens pour garantir l'inclusion et la
participation des personnes en situation
de handicap pour que le droit commun
s'applique en fait à tous les familles
sont dans toute leur diversité le
premier maillon de notre société creuser
d'apprentissagees fondamentaux de la vie
collective et de l'expression des
solidarités le retour du terme famille
dans les dénominations de ministère
n'est pas un hasard c'est bien la
réaffirmation de cette priorité
politique je souhaite m'inscrire dans la
lignée de ce choix fort que notre pays a
fait après la guerre aider toutes les
familles et s'en donner les moyens la
branche famille dépense comme vous le
savez plus de 50 milliards d'euros
chaque année dans cet objectif avec une
hausse en 2024 de l'ordre de 2 milliards
d'euros à mes yeux cette politique
familiale est loin de se résumer à une
simple politique de redistribution c'est
bien avant tout une politique
universelle pour accompagner simplifier
la vie des familles et leur laisser plus
de liberté et de choix pour mettre en
œuvre concrètement cette politique
familiale le PLFSS intègre comme vous le
savez AV à la fois des aides qui sont
monétaires je pense à l'aide de soutien
aux familles c'estàdire la pension
alimentaire minimale dont nous avons
augmenté le montant de 50 % l'an dernier
mais aussi de nouveaux moyens pour
renforcer les services aux familles
simplifier leur vie et mieux répondre à
leurs besoins tout simplement en
respectant leurs choix en 2024 les
moyens consacrés à la politique
familiale augmenteront notamment pour
mettre en œuvre le chantier essentiel du
service public de la petite enfance qui
vise à garantir à tout parents l'accès à
une tion d'accueil de qualité en toute
sécurité que ce soit en crèche chez une
assistante maternelle évidemment de
manière accessible financièrement ce
sont ainsi 6 milliards d'euros qui
seront consacrés jusqu'en 2027 pour
revaloriser nos professionnels de la
petite enfance premier maillon
évidemment de cet accueil soutenir
l'investissement et le fonctionnement
des crèches et engager la dynamique
d'ouverture des 200000 solution
d'accueil manquante que ce soit en
accueil collectif et en accueil
individuel parce qu'un enfant de 10 an
évidemment et j'espère heureusement ne
se garde pas seul et que chaque famille
doit pouvoir accéder aux solutions
adaptées à sa situation les moyens
continueront à monter en puissance en
2025 comme vous le savez avec l'entrée
en vigueur de l'extension de l'aide à la
garde individuelle d'enfants pour les
familles monoparentale et son adaptation
pour toutes les familles afin que le
reste à charge soit bien le même en
accueil individuel et en accueil
collectif ce qui n'était pas le cas
jusqu'alors en fonction du choix
d'assistante maternelle ou d'accueil
collectif je m'assur évidemment que ces
moyens soient dépensés efficacement
c'est-à-dire au service de la qualité de
la prise en charge et de la sécurité de
nos enfants j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
le dire devant vous mais pas un seul des
200 millions d'euros réservés à la
revalorisation des professionnels n'ira
à des groupes qu'ils soient privés
public ou associatif s'ils ne tiennent
pas les engagements pris notamment de
relever par le haut leur convention
collective enfin je n'ignore pas l'écart
grandissant entre le désir d'enfant et
sa réalisation chez nos concitoyens avec
une natalité en baisse tendentielle
depuis 2011 le service public de la
petite enfance est un élément de réponse
fort à ces enjeux et vous pouvez compter
sur ma mobilisation pour continuer à
convaincre sur ce sujet les solidarités
et la famille c'est évidemment tout au
long de la vie c'est pourquoi plus que
jamais l'autonomie est au cœur de
l'action de ce ministère au cœur des
solidarités d'une part parce que
derrière la question de l'autonomie se
cache bien la prise en compte de toutes
les fragilités et l'exigence de garantir
effectivement les droits de chacun et
d'assumer d'assurer la pleine
participation de tous à la vie
collective au cœur des familles d'autre
part parce que toutes les familles sont
concernées par la perte d'autonomie d'un
enfant d'un conjoint d'une mère ou d'un
grand-père et qu'il est donc de notre
devoir d'accompagner ses familles et
plus particulièrement de prendre soin de
ceux qui prennent soin des autres je
pense aux 9 millions d'aidans dans notre
pays au cœur de mon action aussi parce
que je suis convaincue que c'est
collectivement que nous ferons face au
défis si ce n'est au chocs démographiqu
en adaptant dès maintenant notre société
au vieillissement je continue à rabâer
ces deux chiffres qui pour moi sont
essentiels en 2030 un Français sur 3
aura plus de 60 ans et pour la première
fois de notre histoire les plus de 65
ans seront plus nombreux que les moins
de 15 ans en cohérence avec cet
engagement l'objectif global de dépenses
qui finance nos établissements pour
personnes âgées en situation de handicap
augmentera de 4 % en 2024 soit plus que
les 2,5 % d'inflation anticipée cette
hausse importante des moyens traduit le
respect de nos engagements envers les
familles et envers les professionnels du
secteur ces engagements vous les
connaissez c'est d'abord le respect du
libre choix des individus nous le savons
la première demande des Français c'est
de pouvoir vieillir chez eux à domicile
c'est pour répondre à leur volonté que
nous avons entreprise que nous appelons
le virage domiciliaire c'est la question
de l'adaptation de nos logements avec ma
primeadapte qui rentrera en vigueur dès
2024 ce sont des moyens nouveaux dans ce
PLFSS 2024 pour développer de nouveaux
centres de ressources territoriaux enfin
décloisonner les interventionsprès des
personnes âgées à domicile et simplifier
leur démarche celle de leur famille
c'est la dynamique du service public
départemental de l'autonomie objectif un
guichet unique un accueil physique
humain partout mettant fin au parcours
du handicap trop souvent décrit par les
familles que ce soit pour des personnes
âgées pour des personnes en situation de
handicap ce grand projet de
simplification que nous portons depuis
le début de la mandature ancré au cœur
de nos territoires commence à se
concrétiser l'appel la manifestation
d'intérêt auprès des conseils
départementaux a été adressé dès ce mois
de septembre par ailleurs et dans le
prolongement des réformes structurel que
nous menons pour développer et
accompagner les services à domicile des
moyens supplémentaires sont dédiés à
leur montée en charge pour soutenir nos
aide à domicile métier essentiel 99 %
porté par des femmes et qui atteint un
taux de pauvreté de 18 % ce qui signifie
que oui il est plus qu'urgent de
continuer à les revaloriser et que
chacun s'y engage état et département
l'instauration d'un tarif plancher
national pour l'aide à domicile était
d'abord fixé à 22 € en 2022 puis
augmenté à 23 € en 2023 la création
d'une dotation supplémentaire de 3 €
dédié à la qualité du service rendu la
création de 25000 nouvelles places Fiat
d'ici 2030 les 2 heures supplémentaires
par semaine dédié à l'accompagnement et
au liens social pour les personnes
isolés nous continuons de développer sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire aussi des
structures d'habitat intermédiaires je
pense notamment aux accueils familiaux
qui permettent de proposer un
accompagnement très proche du domicile
pour consolider assurer la qualité de
l'offre d'accompagnement des personnes
âgées en établissement le PLFSS 2024
concrétise surtout une nouvelle étape
dans l'objectif de création de 50000
postes supplémentaires dans les éepads
avec une augmentation doublée par
rapport à celle de 2023 puisqu'il
s'agira du recrutement d'environ 6000
professionnels soignants supplémentaires
l'année prochaine recruz vous le savez
ce n'est pas que une question de hausse
des moyens dans un PLFSS c'est surtout
une question d'attractivité des postes
et des carrières c'est pour cela que
j'ai obtenu que les infirmiers les aides
soignantes en NPAD de public bénéficient
de la même mesure de revalorisation pour
le travail de nuit et les jours fériers
que leurs collègues dans les
établissements public sanitaire
sanitaire et médico-social doivent
évidemment avancer de concert enfin
au-delà des enjeux strictement
financiers qui nous concerne aujourd'hui
ce PLFSS prend la mesure de l'urgence
dans laquelle se trouve le secteur des
éepades c'est pourquoi il prévoit une
réforme structurante à partir de 2025 la
possibilité laissée au département et je
dis bien la possibilité qui leur est
laissé de fusion entre les sections
soins et dépendan ce qui permettra un
soutien financier direct au département
et aux épades les plus en difficulté
pour les départements qui le souhaitent
et en lien avec les besoins de soins
croissant des résidents nous le voyons
bien ils entrent de plus en plus tard en
épad dans des épades de plus en plus
médicalisé c'est donc la sécurité
sociale qui financera ainsi la section
dépendance des éepad ce soutien
financier est primordial alors que nous
savons tous ici la situation difficile
si ce n'est presque insoutenable de
nombreux de nos établissements partout
sur nos territoires il s'agit là d'une
dynamique vertueuse pour les personnes
comme pour la soutenabilité de notre
système social avec des frais de soins
évités je souhaite pouvoir enfin avancer
sur la question des fonds de concours au
département en lien avec la CNSA j'ai
l'occasion de le dire en conseil
d'administration cher mononique de la
CNSA c'est un chantier complexe mais je
crois qu'il est temps que nous assumions
de l'adresser parce que 12 fonds de
concours aujourd'hui au sein de la CNSA
l'illisibilité de ces fonds de concours
des politiques menées l'ampilement
successif n'a pas aidé à la prise de
conscience nécessaire sur le choc
démographique qui est devant nous ce
PLFSS est également un texte de mise en
œuvre de nos engagements concernant le
handicap notamment ceux annoncé
directement par le Président de la
République lors de la dernière
conférence nationale du handicap nous
concrétisons ainsi la création de 50 000
solutions pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et pour leurs
proches et volontairement ce sont bien
des solutions mises au pluriel parce que
nous devons veiller à toujours répondre
aux besoins dans toute la diversité et
je pense notamment à nos enfants une
inclusion qui ne soit donc pas
unisolution mais bien multisolution pour
garantir par exemple à chaque enfant le
droit à une scolarité y compris en
milieu et en institut médico-éducatif
assurer une prise en charge adapté aux
enfants en situation de handicap placé à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance puisque 20 %
d'entre eux seraient des enfants en
situation de handicap nous renforçons
les moyens des centres d'action
médico-social précoocce dès 2024 et nous
engageons une mesures clé pour 2025 la
création d'un véritable service de
repérage d'orientation de prise en
charge unifiée de toutes les situations
de handicap pour les enfants de 0 à 6
ans ce dispositif doit permettre d'en
finir avec l'errance des familles et de
lutter contre les pertes de chances de
nos enfants dans cette logique de
prévention que rappelait Aurélien juste
avant je conclurai enfin pour ma part
sur un élément dont je crois nous
pouvons collectivement nous réjouir le
franchissement d'une nouvelle étape
lorsque nous avons voté ensemble en 2020
la création de la branche autonomie à
partir du 1er janvier 2024 vous le savez
015 points de CSG soit 2,6 milliards
d'euros viendront abonder les ressources
de cette 5è branche ce sont notamment
ces moyens qui nous permettront et qui
nous permettent aujourd'hui de tenir les
engagements pris et nous consommons la
moitié de ce surplus dès 2024 enfin
accompagner les plus fragiles c'est
évidemment accompagner leurs proches je
sais que certains d'entre vous sont
d'ailleurs ici directement concernés et
porte ce combat nous avons le devoir de
prendre soin de ceux qui prennent soin
des autres car devenir aidant c'est non
seulement une responsabilité mais on le
sait c'est aussi une charge physique
mentale extrêmement lourde à porter avec
la nouvelle stratégie que nous avons
présenté avec Fadila katabi nous
permettons d'amplifier le soutien
nécessaire aux aidans garantir quoi
qu'il arrive 15 jours de répis comme
nous nous y étions engagés garantir des
plateformes de répi partout sur le
territoire créer 6000 nouvelles
solutions d'accueil et de répi
permettant d'ici 2027 d'avoir 40000
solutions partout sur notre territoire
c'est un pas essentiel je crois qu'il y
a 10 ans le mot aidant n'existait pas ce
mot aidant aujourd'hui il est reconnu
avec des droits qui y sont attachés et
des droits qui sont renforcés grâce à
vous dans ce P FSS je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre délégué au comptes publ je vous
en prie
merci Madame la la présidente Madame et
et Monsieur le Ministre madame la la
rapporteur générale Stéphanie ris
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
très heureux d'être devant vous devant
la commission des affaires sociales avec
Aurore berger Aurélien Rousseau pour
présenter le projet loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour pour 2024
d'abord je pense qu'on peut être fier de
ce texte car continue d'investir on y
reviendra massivement dans la protection
sociale des français tout en poursuivant
la maîtrise des équilibres financiers je
voudrais remercier la Direction de la
Sécurité sociale et toutes les les
services des administrations qui ont
contribué à construire ce texte j'étais
il y a quelques jours devant vos
collègues de la commission des des
finances pour porter le projet loi de
finances pour 2024 et celui de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
2023-2027 aussi permettez-moi d'abord de
souligner la cohérence entre ces textes
C financier et le de la sécurité sociale
à la fois dans l'esprit dans les
objectifs qui nous animent
collectivement
sur l'esprit c'est celui de la
responsabilité financière qui est la
seule manière de garantir la pérennité
d'un système de protection sociale
auquel nos concitoyens sont très
attachés et c'est ce qui guide notre
action protéger nos concitoyens des plus
jeunes aux plus âgés et leur permettre
de préparer sereinement leur avenir ce
PLFSS 2024 s'inscrit ainsi dans la
démarche plus global de maîtrise des
dépenses publiques sur le champ des
administrations de sécurité sociale
comme sur les autres autrees champ de la
dépense publique il contribue ainsi à
l'atteinte de l'objectif de réduction du
déficit public et son retour sous la
barre des 3 % à horizon de 2027 ce n'est
pas un totem c'est tout simplement le
niveau d'avant-crise que nous avons pu
constater en 2018 et et en 2019 par
ailleurs ce PLFSS doit contribuer à la
soutenabilité globale de notre
trajectoire et à la maîtrise de notre
dette selon un double principe d'effort
partagé et de logique graduelle qui sont
ceux de la loi de programmation ou du
projet de loi de finances nous avons je
crois trouvé un juste point d'équilibre
entre responsabilité et investissement
dans l'avenir ainsi comme vous le savez
la sécurité sociale ne reviendra pas à
l'équilibre dans les prochaines années
la dynamique naturelle des dépenses joue
même en sens contraire c'est notamment
l'effet de la démographie mais aussi du
renchérissement associé au progrès
médical pour préserver notre capacité à
accompagner le Bien vieillir ou à offrir
un soin à l'état de l'art des mesures de
maîtrise des dépenses sont nécessaires
dès 2024 et que d'autres devront être
prises à partir de 2025 et je le redis
ici à hauteur de 6 milliards d'euros je
suis confiant dans notre capacité
collective à faire face à cette
contrainte partagé que personne ne peut
nier ainsi des réformes courageuses ont
été conduites je pense notamment aux
réformes de l'assurant chômage mais
aussi à la réforme des retraites portée
par notre collègue Olivier du sopt dans
un dans un compte de nette amélioration
du retour à l'emploi mais nous devons
encore mais nous devons encore trouver
des marges pour permettre à notre
système de perdurer mais aussi d'évoluer
en ligne avec nos priorités qui ont été
rappelé par Aurélien Rousseau et Aurore
berger mettre davantage l'action
notamment sur la prévention et je m'en
réjouis dans ce contexte le PLFSS 2024
traduit à la fois un engagement soutenu
en faveur de notre système de protection
sociale et une amélioration de la
régulation des dépenses notamment dans
le champ de la santé
des mesures importantes ont été adoptées
cette année pour favoriser
l'attractivité des métiers dans les
établissements sanitaires et médicaux
sociaux elle représente un
investissement très conséquent elles
expliquent en partie même en grande
partie le réhaussement de long d'AM de
2,8 milliards d'euros en 2023 à laquelle
procède ce PLFSS en 2024 ces mesures
d'attractivité décidées en 2023 coûte
plus de 3 milliards d'euros si on inclut
le relèvement du point d'indice de 3,5 %
en 22 cela nous amène à plus de 6
milliards de gains supplémentaires pour
les professionnels l'année prochaine
sans même prendre en compte les effets
du plan segure l'ONDAM 2024 poursuit son
soutien aux établissements sanitaires le
sous-objectif qui leur est dédié
dépassant 100 milliards d'euros soit un
niveau historique de même dans le champ
médico-social le PLFSS prévoit dans la
continuité notamment du rapport de
Madame Christine piiresbonne une réforme
du financement des éepad comme le
rappelait Aurore berger les départements
pourront s'ils le souhaitent engager une
fusion des sections soins et dépendance
et je rappelle aussi que l'ONDA
médico-social intègre les 100 millions
d'euros annoncés par la première
ministre cet été dans le cadre du fond
d'urgence donc au total l'ONDAM 2024
progressera de 3,2 % soit un niveau
supérieur de plusieurs points à celui de
l'inflation qui s'établira quant à elle
à 2,5 % en 2024 en dehors de l'ONDAM je
souhaite rappeler que le gouvernement
maintient un système protecteur
d'indexation des prestations sur
l'inflation qui pour les retraites
représente 14 milliards d'euros et pour
les prestations familial plus d'un
milliard d'euros ces montants dans la
situation actuelle de nos finances
publiques reflètent un vrai engagement
une vraie priorité ce PLFSS y marque
aussi notre engagement en faveur de la
régulation des dépenses ainsi concernant
plus particulièrement les dépenses de
santé des économies sont prévus par
exemple il a l'incitation au recours au
transports sanitaires partagés ou dans
le champ des produits de santé nous nous
sommes fixés un objectif d'économie de
1,3 milliards d'euros réparti entre 1
milliard d'euros de baisse de prix et
0,3 milliards d'euros de baisse des
volumes le texte initial du PLFSS
comporte de premières mesures pour favor
favoriser cette maîtrise des des volume
le ministre de la Santé l'a rappelé
notamment les tests trod ou bien le
conditionnement à l'unité en cas de
risque de rupture d'approvisionnement et
les travaux vont se poursuivre pour
trouver d'autres leviers de régulation
qui répondent à un triple jeu financier
bien sûr mais aussi sanitaire et
environnemental au total ces mesures de
maîtrise permettent de limiter de
limiter la dégradation tendantielle et
nous devrons poursuivre ses efforts au
cours des années suivantes je crois à
notre modèle social et c'est pourquoi
nous préservons ces ressources les
cotisations sociales demeurent le socle
de financement de notre sécurité sociale
alors même que nous avons affecté de
nouvelles ressources de CSG à la jeune
branche autonomie crée en 2020 la part
des cotisations s'établit toujours à a
près de 50 % des recettes des régimes
obligatoires avec une croissance prévue
de plus de 4 % en 2024 nous devons
d'abord la progression de ces ressources
au dynamisme de notre marché du travail
plus de 125000 créations de postes entre
juillet 22 et 23 2 millions d'emplois
créé depuis 2017 et c'est pour ça que
nous continuons nos efforts pour
atteindre le plein emploi et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'une partie des excédents de
l'Unedic qui résulte des réformes
conduites en matière d'assurance chômage
et du marché du travail sera affecté au
fin
du développement des compétences et à
France travail pour conforter le retour
à l'emploi des personnes bénéficiaires
du RSA alors s'agissant des politiques
en faveur de l'emploi la question des
allagements généraux est revenue sur le
devant de la scène si je puis dire à
l'occasion du rapport tout récemment
rendu par laamex dont je veux saluer la
qualité nous avons fait à ce stade le
choix de maintenir ces allègements ils
sont un élément extrêmement structurant
des pratiques salariales des
comportements de recrutement des
employeurs et je pense qu'on ne peut y
toucher qu'avec une grande prudence en
particulier dans cette période où n dev
vons tout faire pour soutenir et
l'activité et le pouvoir d'achat et dans
ce cadre il nous semble que des
réflexions et des consultations
supplémentaires sont nécessaires en
particulier dans le cadre de la
conférence sociale qui va s'ouvrir comme
vous le savez dans quelques jours enfin
j'ai souhaité que ce PLFSS comme
d'ailleurs le PLF soit celui de la lutte
contre la frudte sociale cette dernière
constitue un impératif d'équité et de
justice sociale à la fois pour
l'ensemble des des assurés il n'est pas
admissible que certains élus de leur
cotisation perçoivent indument des
prestations abuse de leur expertise
comme nous avons pu le voir dans
l'actualité la plus récente et vous
retrouverez dans ce PLFSS un certain
nombre de mesures je n'en cite que
certaines d'entre elles notamment le le
la sécurisation du paiement des
cotisations des travailleurs des
plateformes les sanctions contre les
professionnels de santé fraudeur seront
renforcées le mécanisme de l'avance
immédiate au crédit d'impôt service à la
personne sera lui aussi simplifié et
resséré et enfin j'ai demandé à la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale de
travailler à la création d'un déliit de
promotion de la frotte sociale comme
nous l'avons déjà dans le PLF le déli
d'incitation à la fraude
fiscale enfin je voulais terminer sur ce
point en vous rappelant enfin vous
indiquant que j'ai installé le Conseil
d'évaluation de toutes les fraudes il y
a maintenant 2 jours qui réunit des
experts d'horizon très différents à
laquelle participent d'ailleurs certains
parlementaires pour nous permett
d'évaluer complètement la réalité de la
fraude fiscale et sociale en conclusion
je voudrais vous redire ma détermination
d'une part à trouver les ressources
nécessaires pour la mise en œuvre des
priorités fondamentales partagées en
matière sanitaire et sociale mais aussi
celle de tenir nos mesures d'économie
qui sont nécessaires qui sont
nécessaires à la soutenabilité de notre
système je vous je vous remercie pour
votre attention et vous prie par
ailleurs de m'excuser par avance parce
que je vrais vous quitter un peu après
18h pour rejoindre le Sénat
merci merci madamees et messieurs les
ministres madame la rapporteur général
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues je suis ravie que nous
nous retrouvions aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de ce deè projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale de
cette 16e
législature ce PLFSS pour 2024 traduit
un grand nombre d'engagements du
président de la République du
gouvernement mesure que notre majorité a
porté lors de sa campagne je pense ici
par exemple à la réforme du financement
des établissements de santé pour
diminuer qui permettra de diminuer la
part de la tarification à l'activité un
financement plus équitable notamment
pour nos maternités et nos services de
réanimation c'est plus de 155,6
milliards d'euros qui seront consacrés
aux établissements de santé permettant
de financer les
récentes annonces de et de
d'attractivité et de revalorisation des
professionnels de santé à ce sujet les
internes de nos hôpitaux bénéficient
aussi de revalorisation de leur garde de
50 % jusqu'au 31 décembre 2023 il
s'inquiète de savoir si ces mesures les
concerneront aussi en 2024 avec ces
revalorisations et la prise en compte de
l'inflation l'ONDAM 2023 est rectifié
avec une hausse de 4,8% et de plus de
3,2 % en 2024 3,5 pour la médecine de
ville malgré tout l'ensemble des
fédération malgré tout l'ensemble des
fédérations hospitalières des acteurs
nous alertent nous interpelle sur cette
hausse qu'ils estime
insuffisante si nous dépensons plus pour
nos établissements de santé nous devons
pour cela maîtriser un certain nombre de
dépenses en promouvant la pertinence et
la qualité des soins depuis plusieurs
années d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes et
des associ assoation de patients
soulligne la nécessaire évolution du
financement de la dialyse il me semble
que nous pourrions en effet faire
évoluer ce financement comme celui
d'ailleurs de la radiothérapie je veux
saluer dans ce texte la confirmation de
nos engagements en matière de prévention
c'est plus de 150 millions d'euros qui
est consacré dans ce PLFSS vous en avez
rappelé les mesures il nous faut
poursuivre dans la prévention je
souhaite attirer votre attention sur
notre capacité à éviter les survenu de
situations de handicap pouvant induite
par des infections à cytomégalovirus CMV
pendant le premier trimestre de
grossesse responsable d'une grande
majorité des handicap neurosensoriel par
infection Matern fétal je souhaite avec
plusieurs de mes collègues rendre le
dépistage du CMV systématique au premier
trimestre de grossesse à toutes les
femmes enceintes je sais Monsieur le
Ministre votre intérêt sur la prévention
pouvez-vous me dire ce que vous en
pensez par ailleurs je proposerai aussi
que toutes les femmes qui le souhaitent
puissent avoir une consultation dédiée à
la ménopause p période de la vie qui
nécessite une meilleure prise en charge
concernant la santé des femmes sur le
plan budgétaire il est de notre
responsabilité de veiller à la
soutenabilité vous l'avez dit monsieur
le ministre de notre système de
protection sociale qui nous a permis
d'ailleurs par par exemple de faire
collectivement face à la crise sanitaire
la situation des côes sociaux en
particulier de l'assurance vieillesse
l'assurance maladie reste trop fragile à
moyen terme le redressement des comptes
devra donc se poursuivre et passera sans
doute par de nouveaux fort ce texte
prévoit un certain nombre de mesures de
régulation des dépenses qui vont dans ce
sens baisse du prix des médicaments dans
le secteur de la biologie et un
renforcement des moyens de lutte contre
les fraudes sociales ces mesures sont
nécessaires si nous souhaitons tendre
vers l'équilibre et assurer la viabilité
de notre système de protection sociale
je vous
remercie merci
oui madame madame la rapporteur
thématique sur l'autonomie madame
janvier merci Madame la présidente
messieur madame la ministre et bien pour
commencer je voudrais saluer un effort
ambitieux important en faveur de la
branche autonomie qui totalise
aujourd'hui un objectif de dépense à
39,9 milliards d'euros soit une
augmentation de 5 % par rapport à
l'exercice précédent effort qui se
traduit avec des mesures très concrètes
he la poursuite de la trajectoire des
50000 soignants c'est plus 6000 postes
sur cet exercice une meilleure
rémunération également avec les
suggestions nuit et weekend qui étent
long demandé de longuees dates et
s'agissant des personnes en situation de
handicap c'est le début de la
concrétisation des annonces faites en
CNH avec cet objectif de 1,5 milliards à
horizon 2030 et j'aurais voulu en savoir
un peu plus sur la façon dont ces
montants vont être déployés sur cet
exercice
2024 euh de la même façon sur le plan
organisationnel avec cette réforme de la
fusion des sections qui répond là aussi
à une attente très ancienne du secteur
je j'ai été sollicité par un certain
nombre d'entre eux et et leurs
représentants qui souhaitent être
assurés sur la généralisation à moyen
long terme parce qu'ils sont évidemment
très favorable à cette fusion des
sections euh même si le problème de la
soutenabilité financière de ces
abissement et celui du reste à charge
reste évidemment entier s'agissant des
services à domicile je crois que cet
exercice budgétaire est l'occasion de
faire un point d'étape et il serait
intéressant en effet d'évaluer les
efforts que nous avons fait et les
mesures appliqué et vootter lors des
derniersres exercices budgétaires enfin
je profite des 10 secondes récentes pour
interroger monsieur le ministre de la
Santé sur la généralisation du cannabis
thérapeutique je vous remercie merci
pour la précision du temps madame
Jeanvie euh monsieur Cyril Isaac cbil
rapporteur thématique vieillesse merci
madame la présidente Madame et Messieurs
les ministre chers collègues euh merci
pour la prentation que vous avez faite
du projet de loi de finances de la
séurité sociale pour 2024 qui traduit
l'engagement du gouvernement en faveur
d'un renforcement de notre système de
sécurité sociale en tant que rapporteur
de la branche vieillesse je limiterai
mon intervention mon intervention aux
enjeux financiers de notre système de
RET
si nous nous félicitons de la
revalorisation prévue des pensions de
retraite de 5,2 % dès le 1er janvier
2024 les annexes au pfss anticipent en
déficite de la branche vieillesse et du
fond solidé vieillesse de 11,2 milliards
d'euros en 2027 si la réforme des
retraites n'avait pas été adoptée ce
déficite serait supérieur de 6,3
milliards d'euros ce qui illustre
l'évidente nécessité des mesures que
nous avons prises la réforme des
retraites reposé sur un sur un principe
simple que l'ensemble des régimes
participe à la nécessaire solidarité
financière au sein du système de
retraite je note à ce titre que le le
projet de loi prévoit pour participer au
financement des retraites de transférer
à la séurité sociale dès 2024 une part
TVA à hauteur de 192 millions d'euros au
titre des gains résultants de la réforme
pour le régime de la fonction publique
d'État ce montant s'accroitrait dans les
années à venir pour atteindre 520
millions d'euros en 2027 s'agissant des
régimes complémentaires l'article 9 de
ce projet de loi prévoit de permettre à
la cave et à l'AG Carco de signer une
convention permettant la prise en charge
du financement permettant l'extinction
attendue des régimes
spéciaux cependant l'accord national
interprofessionnel trouvé la semaine
dernière par les partenaires sociaux
chargés de la gestion de la GCO n'a
malheureusement pas pris en compte la
question de la contribution de ce régime
au financement des mesures de solidarité
en faveur des petites retraites qui
bénéficient aussi au retraité du privé
pouvez-vous nous rappeler les futurs
gains générés par cette réforme pour le
régime géré par l'arger Carco réforme
que notre majorité a pourtant été bien
seule apportter merci pouvez-vous
préciser ce que le gouvernement englobe
dans les éléments de solidarité
financière au sein de ce système de
retraite et pouvez-vous nous communiquer
le montant du de cette solidarité que
seul not système de sécurité sociale
porte minimum vieillesse minimum
contributif majoré qui pourtant bénéfici
au
salariés là vraiment vous abusez de ma
gentillesse monsieur Ruffin mais
n'oubliez pas qu'il y a aussi les
questions des députés par la suite et
les orateurs de groupe monsieur Ruffin
rapporteur thématique de la branchem
monsieur ministre vous avez parlé la
dynamique des dépenses d'arrêts maladie
et c'est vrai c'est vrai que depuis une
décennie il y a une augmentation de ces
arrêts maladie et vous en appelez à la
responsabilisation de chacun mais quelle
est la première cause de l'augmentation
de ces arrêts maladies c'est dans
l'annexe du plan de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui nous est donné où
il est écrit cette croissance dépenses
indemnité journalière maladie s'explique
principalement par l'augmentation et le
vieillissement de la population active
ça veut dire quoi en clair ça veut dire
que ce sont les réformes des retraites
successives qui amènent les gens à
vieillir au travail à être malade au
travail et du coup avoir des arrêts
maladies ça veut dire quoi avec les
mesures qui sont mises en place c'est
qu'on a aujourd'hui une triple peine
c'est-à-dire les salariés dont un la
santé est fragilisée par le travail vont
deux devoir partir en retraite plus tard
et en plus trois seront montrés du doigt
et pénalisés s'ils sont malades s'ils se
retrouvent en arrêt maladie c'est dire
l'injustice de ce qui va être mis en
œuvre la deuxème cause la deuxème cause
de ces
os des arrt maladies c'est le mal
travail le mal au travail un mal travail
français il est montré dans les
comparaisons internationales tant sur
les accidents du travail mais aussi sur
le stress sur le port de chargeelourge
sur les tas de facteurs que la France a
une spécificité dans le mal travail qui
par ailleurs coûre à not économist sans
doute au allour de 100 milliards d'euros
par
an quand il y a ça il y a ce maltil qui
avait été finalement reconnu par euh les
ministres ce printemps quand il disait
le président de la République il nous
fallait un nouveau pacte de la vie au
travail
et tous les médecins là disent quoi
quand on dit qu'on va les mettre sous
objectifs que il va y avoir des alertes
disent mes patients bossent en usine ou
en blamatoire ils sont manutentionnaires
ou soignants ils sont usés par
l'intensité du travail mais ils
attendent d'être au bout du bout pour
venir me voir je ne me vois pas leur
dire désolé j'ai atteint mon quotat je
réduis la durée de votre arrêt les
mesures que vous mettez en œuvre sur les
indemnités des journalières pour moi
elles ne sont pas dans la bonne
philosophie monsieur le ministre là
pourquoi parce que ce qu'il faut revoir
et c'est ce que prévoyaient les assises
national du travail ils réclament tous
dans leur recommandations quoi qu'on
revoit l'organisation du travail que la
vie en entreprise soit revue et avec la
la participation des salariés or vous
vous partez pas je vous partez pas sur
le le la réorganisation collecti vous
voyez pas ça vous responsabilisez
c'est-à-dire vous culpabilisez vous
faites peser la faute sur des individus
et sur des médecins qui en serit les
complices
merci je vais donner la parole dans un
premier temps au ministre pour des
premiers éléments de réponse assez
succent s'il vous plaît madame et
messieurs les ministres puisqueensuite
on aura les orateurs de groupe puis les
questions des députés mais pour
permettre notamment monsieur casazenav
de d'apporter certaines éléments de
réponse merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et Messieurs les les
rapporteurs peut-être par rapport au au
points soulevés par la la rapporteur
général peut-être red dire que la
modification du financement en effet ça
fait longtemps qu'on en parle elle est
inscrite concrètement dans le texte avec
des activités standard normées qui
demeurent financé à l'activité
c'est-à-dire financé à la T2A mais avec
deux blocs supplémentaires un bloc qui
répond aux objectifs de santé publique
qui seront financé par des dotations
spécifiques et notamment pour prendre en
compte la la spécificité et la réalité
territoriale des établissements et puis
de l'autre côté du spectre de la prise
en charge et du soin les activités
spécifique 3ème bloc se verront quant à
elle financé par des dotations identifié
par activité urgence activités de
recours soins critique activité non
programmable je crois qu'on a là une
évolution structurante et structurelle
qui a fait l'objet d'un énorme travail
de la direction générale de l'offre de
soins de la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale que je tiens à saluer et qui a
fait l'objet d'un accord global des
fédérations madame la rapporteur
générale vous soullignez à juste titre
le le la convergence des remontées des
fédérations sur l'impact de
l'inflation sur la situation des
établissements de
santé cet impact il est réel je je ne
vais pas le le le le cacher et nous
sommes en train en ce moment même de
regarder comment dans des condition que
vous connaissez nous pourrons appuyer
les établissements pour ne pas les faire
basculer dans le rouge à un moment comme
je le disais en introduction où nous
essayons de de consolider des signes
positifs qu'on qu'on qu'on commence à
voir mais oui il y a un sujet inflation
oui il y a urgence à poser le principe
d'un d'un appui et après nous verrons
jusqu'où nous pourrons aller dans cet
appui je part partage madame la
rapporteur générale mais vous le savez
euh votre euh réflexion sur euh la
dialyse et la radiothérapie pour élargir
un peu le spectre par rapport à ce que
vous avez indiqué il s'agit de se
demander si dans les actes de soins il y
en a qui sont d'une certaine manière
sous-financés et d'autres surfinancés et
à ce moment-là ils deviennent d'une
certaine manière des rentes et donc euh
il faut passer de l'activité sans doute
au forfait c'est un chantier que je suis
euh tout à fait prêt à ouvrir je je
partage votre
votre préoccupation et euh euh ce que
vous soullignez sur le site omégalovirus
et notamment euh la le le principe d'un
test qui permet aussi beaucoup plus de
sérénité au cours de la grossesse il
comis dans le rapport entre la maman et
ses premiers enfant si elle en a euh ce
sont des dispositions de nature
réglementaire mais en tout ét état de
cause je pense que c'est un point
important de même globalement alors je
reviens pas sur la ménopause en
particulier mais qu'on a de plus en plus
de de de y compris de littérature sur la
nécessité d'avoir des consultations
médicales dans les périodes dites de
transition et je pense évidemment par
construction que la ménopause en étude
je voudrais dire juste un mot sur les
fraudes sociales mais ça renverra j'y
reviendrai un tout petit peu plus
longuement sur la sur la question de de
de de de Monsieur Ruffin euh ce ne sont
pas seulement les bénéficiaires qui
fraudent et pour lever toute ambiguïé
les plus gros fraudeurs ne sont pas les
plus modestes voilà c'est la courbe est
strictement inverse donc cette fraude
elle s'applique à tous les acteurs et la
recherche elle s'applique à tous les
acteurs et aujourd'hui nous avons y
compris des outils beaucoup plus
performants du côté de l'assurance
maladie qui permettent de repérer euh
des parcours de soins anormaux et
quelques fraudes quelquefois qui sont
vraiment des fraudes organisées et donc
nous les débusquerons et ce sont des
centaines de millions d'euros qui sont
en jeu à chaque fois par rapport à la
question de de Caroline janvier question
posée en quelques secondes pour un sujet
qui qui qui qui qui est un peu qui est
qui qui est sensible évidemment euh pour
le dire le plus simplement possible vous
avez voté une expérimentation relative
au cannabis à usage médical qui prend
fin en mars 2024 on est dans une
situation où on a des des retours
cliniques si je puis dire qui font état
d'un bénéfice pour le patient euh on n'a
pas à ce stade d'autorisation de mise
sur le marché à l'échelle européenne qui
serait prête pour 2025 donc l'engagement
que je prends ici c'est que le
gouvernement présentera un amendement
pour qu'évidemment tous les
bénéficiaires de ces euh de ces euh de
cette expérimentation puisse continuer à
en bénéficier et qu'on ait un statut ad
hoc pour le cannabis thérapeutique un
statut adapté qui nous permettent
ensuite de voir dans la durée soit il y
a AMM européenne soit il n'y a pas si
après on bascule typiquement dans un
plutôt un accès dit compassionnel vous
vous connaissez vous connaissez ce
vocabulaire qui ne signifie pas
exactement ce qu'il ce qu'il veut dire
en bon français mais il y aura bien un
statut ad hoc pour le cannabis
thérapeutique et aucune interruption de
des traitements pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui en bénéficient euh peut-être
monsieur le député Ruffin sur sur
Accident du travail maladie
professionnelle je je je je je suis on
en avait déjà évoqué petit un je l'ai
dit dans mon introduction vous avez
raison euh l'augmentation des du du de
la dynamique des indemnités journalières
c'est une dynamique qui est d'abord
tirée par par la croissance de la
population active c'est ce qui est une
ce qui est une bonne nouvelle la
croissance de la population active
deuxièmement je vais pas me là aussi
raconter d'histoire le ce qui fait
croître le plus fortement les indemnités
journalières ce ne sont pas les
indemnités des des arrêts très courts ce
sont les arrêts longs donc les arrêts
longs oui ça renvoie à des questions de
travail de prévention de la pénibilité
d'anticipation de la pénibilité de
reconversion professionnelle d'où la
cohérence avec d'autres mesures du PLFSS
Olivier du SOP n'est pas là mais
pourrait les présenter qui sont des
nouvelles opportunités et qui ont été
dans la célèbre réforme des retraites
que vous qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
par Thomas qui ont été pris en compte
mais je suis d'accord avec vous le sujet
et je pense que la conférence sociale
qui sera que tiendra la première
ministre la semaine prochaine y viendra
on a un sujet qui renvoie au mal travail
pas que au mal travail je pense qu'on a
un sujet euh je sais sa que c'est une
préoccupation qui est très largement
partagée ici sur la santé mentale
globale dans la population quand je dis
santé mentale c'est évidemment pas que
de la santé psy mais un sujet de santé
mentale on a une évolution du rapport au
monde du travail c'est certains dans les
éléments d'explosion on a une explosion
des arrêts très courts chez les très
jeunes salariés il nous appartient de la
comprendre mais pas forcément pas
nécessairement et je pense c'est inutile
de la de la stigmatiser vous avez
ensuite présenter les trois la triple
peine et notamment le le le le le la la
douleur infligée par ce PLFSS sur les Ig
je la cherche puisque nous avons
précisément indiqué que nous allions y
travailler et de de mémoire il n y a une
mesure à l'article 27 sur sur les les
indamités journalières mais c'est la
seule et enfin pour finir sur ça il
n'est pas question de la même manière de
cibler soit le prescripteur soit soit le
bénéficiaire entre guillemets je mets
plein de guillemet un bénéficiaire de
cet arrêt de travail il est question
d'avoir une approche globale j'avoue je
vous le dis très simplement qu'un
médecin qui prescrit quatre fois plus à
patientelle égale d'arrêt de travail que
son confrère ça ne me choque pas que
l'assurance maladie aille discuter avec
lui évidemment quelquefois il y a des
formules et des courriers de l'assurance
maladie qui sont un peu expéditif et on
travaille sur sur ce sujet-là mais dans
le même m état d'esprit j'ai demandé à
l'assurance assurance maladie monsieur
le député de cibler et d'identifier les
entreprises dans lesquels les arrêts
maladies explosent parce que il y a
aussi une responsabilité des employeurs
d'ors et déjà l'assurance maladie est
identifié 200 entreprises dans
lesquelles les arrêts maladies explosent
donc il n'y a pour moi aucune
stigmatisation on ne on ne on avancera
sur ces sujets que par la
responsabilisation collective et donc
oui vous vous avez je je vous avez
raison il y a un sujet de l'allongement
des carrières on ne pourra pas reprocher
à la réforme des retraites qui a été
adoptée cette année d'y être pour
quelque chose pour les chiffres de cette
année il y a un sujet de prescription et
il y a évidemment un sujet de la
responsabilité des employeurs et on est
le gouvernement est bien décidé à à à
prendre de front ces
différentes dimensions voilà pour les
premières réponses
oui pour répondre à la rapporteur
Caroline janvier non pas sur le cannabis
mais sur plutôt la branche
autonomie alors plusieurs il y a pas de
lien je crois pas sur plusieurs sujets
sur la question de la fusion des
sections l'idée c'est vraiment de s'er
sur le volontariat des département sur
sur cette question c'est pour ça que ce
sera une possibilité qui est ouverte au
département ce que j'ai demandé c'est
qu'on puisse faire des évaluations
département par département de
l'évolution démographique et de l'impact
budgétaire que ça aurait de manière à ce
que les départements puissent juger en
toute connaissance de cause mais encore
une fois parce que on a des départements
qui sont dans des situations
démographiques très différentes et dans
des situations financières très
différentes qui n'est pas d'imposer une
généralisation au département mais bien
de laisser cette possibilité qui est
ouverte sur les services à domicile ce
dont je vous ai parlé c'est bien une
montée en puissance pour 2024 pour être
plus précise le tarif planché donc le
passage de 22 à 23 € qui doit Contin à
augmenter c'est 400 millions d'euros euh
en 2024 la dotation qualité c'est du
même ordre 400 millions d'euros et on
démarre bien les 2 heures de
convivialité que nous avions adopté l'an
dernier c'est 100 millions d'euros sur
ensuite comment on implémente
progressivement les annonces CNH et les
1,5 milliards d'euros de la trajectoire
dès 2024 donc il y a en effet c'est
50000 solutions on va pouvoir faire
partir des appels à projet via les ARS
dès le mois de janvier moi ce que je
veux en priorité c'était une des
réponses que j'avais apporté à député
Valentin hier c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui
10000 adultes qui se retrouvent dans des
établissements qui sont des
établissements pour enfant du fait vous
le savez des amendements cretons donc
moi la priorité absolue dans les appels
à projet qu'on va lancer c'est d'abord
évidemment que des solutions soit
apporté un pour apporter des solutions
pertinentes à ces adultes qui ne
devraient pas être encore une fois dans
des établissements pour mineurs ce qui
dé facto libère aussi des places dans
ces établissements ou encore une fois
qui ont été pensé et créé pour pour nos
enfants donc là c'est vraiment la
première brique qu'on doit apporter dès
2024 et peut-être deux deux
compléments pour répondre à à Stéphanie
Rist nous on est très preneur de
d'engager avec vous de nouveaux travaux
pour identifier de nouvelles pistes
d'économie comme je dit on a besoin de
faire d'autres économies au-delà de 2024
dè 2025 donc toutes les pistes y compris
celles que vous avez identifié nous
sommes naturellement avec Aurélien
Rousseau à votre disposition pour les
creuser sur la question agir Carco
soulevé par Cyril Isaac sibil juste ça
me permet de de relarifier une ou deux
choses il n'a jamais été question de
ponctionner les excédents de laagir
Carco ce que j'ai pu lire ça et là la
réforme des retraites
elle génère un excédent j'allais dire
sur l'excédent c'est-à-dire elle permet
d'améliorer le régime ce qu'on a évalué
entre de 2026 et 2030 entre 1,2
milliards et 3 milliards d'euros donc on
a identifié quel est l'effet de la
réforme des retraites sur la situation
de l'agir Carco on regarde pas les
excédents les excédents ils
appartiennent à laag Carco et on dit
juste on a porté cette réforme des
retraites avec un objectif d'améliorer
l'équilibre financier global du système
des retraites général et complémentaire
on dit juste que cet excédent
supplémentaire il doit participer à
l'équilibre d'ensemble de notre régime
c'est tout ce que nous disons il n'a
jamais été question de faire autre chose
d'aller récupérer les excédents générés
ça là on dit juste que cette mesure
cette réforme des retraites elle a
généré un accident qui doit participer
c'était le sens de la réforme que nous
avons porter un meilleur équilibre
financier merci madamees et messieurs
les ministres nous allons passer
maintenant aux questions et aux propos
des orateurs de groupe et comme les
rapporteurs ont été très gourmands en
temps je vais être intraitable cette
fois puisqueen plus les orateurs ont
droit à 4 minutes chacun et nous
démarrons avec Monsieur Roussé et Madame
Christol qui se partageront ces deux ces
4 minutes pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je tiens
d'abord à remercier les ministres pour
leur présentation ce texte présente un
double visage celui de la responsabilité
financière mais aussi nous ne l'gigons
pas
celui d'investissement important pour
notre système de de santé un texte
d'investissement l'ondant progresse de
3,2 % hors les dépenses liées à la crise
sanitaire c'est une augmentation
significative qui va au-delà de
l'inflation contraireement ma ce qui a
pu être dit c'est 8 milliards de plus
par rapport à 2023 très concrètement ce
budget c'est 252 milliards d'euros pour
l'Assurance Maladie c'est-à-dire des
mesures ambitieuses en en matière de
prévention et d'accès aux soins sur les
vaccinations la santé des femmes la
contraception la prévention des
affections bucodentaires le renforcement
des équipes de soins la santé mentale
fait aussi partie de la de la prévention
et nous devons assurer le renforcement
du soutien psychiatrique et
psychologique de la population et nousou
noublions pas investir dans la
prévention c'est miser sur l'avenir
c'est garantir une meilleure santé pour
nos concitoyens mais c'est aussi limité
de futures dépenses c'est tout
l'ambition de ce texte mais ce texte
c'est aussi un texte de responsabilité
la lutte contre la fraude est donc un
véritable enjeu l'assurance maladie a
encore très récemment confirmé son
engagement à détecter et stopper 500
millions d'euros de fraude social en
2024 c'est l'essentiel et grâce aux
nouveaux outils proposés dans ce PLFSS
chacun prendra sa part de responsabilité
les professionnels de santé les
laboratoires et les particuliers nous
devons également être vigilant vigilant
aux investissements que nous consacrons
à l'utilisation par exemple des
dispositifs médicaux implatbles qui
doivent avant tout servir les besoins
des patients vous l'aurez compris certes
une maîtrise budgétaire s'impose mais
après une période de soutien important
pendant la crise sanitaire mais elle
n'empêche en rien la défense d'une
amélioration du modèle de soins je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente à
mon tour de remercier Madame et messieur
les ministrre pour leur présentation
au-delà des chiffres et des lettres ce
PLFSS continue de traduire des priorités
et des engagements du gouvernement qui
avec responsabilité soutien notre
système de protection sociale dans la
durée ce sont notamment des engagements
forts pour la prévention la réforme
attendue du financement de nos
établissements de santé qui sont des
mesures fortes qui me tiennent à cœur
mais sur lesquelles notre collègue
Jean-François Rousset est déjà revenu ce
sont aussi des engagements très concrets
en faveur des personnes en perte
d'autonomie avec des mesures attendues
malgré les difficultés conjoncturelles
et structurelles que connaît le secteur
3 ans après sa création la branche
autonomie continue de prendre corps avec
une hausse sans précédent des moyens
alloués et les chiffres ont été é
rapporté derrière les chiffres ce sont
des engagements concrets face aux
épreuves que peuvent endurer nos
concitoyens je pense aux personnes en
situation de handicap nous trouvons ici
les premiers engagements concrets de la
Conférence nationale du handicap qui a
défini les besoins à hauteur de 1,5
milliard d'euros d'ici 2030 en lettrre
ou en chiffre je pense au remboursement
des fauteuils roulants dès l'année
prochaine aux 50000 solutions et à la
création du service précoce de repérage
et d'accompagnement et je pense bien
entendu aux personnes âgées le bien ir
trouve lui corord dans des différentes
mesures adoptées depuis 6 ans on
retrouve le financement des mesures
engagées notamment pour respecter le
souhait des Français de vivre à domicile
et l'amorce d'une mesure qui est
attendue par de nombreux acteurs de très
longue date à savoir la clarification du
financement des épad et des USLD avec la
fusion des soins et despendances dans
les départements volontaires il faudra
ensuite qu'une généralisation puisse se
déployer rapidement le retour prochain
de la proposition de loi bienvire doit
nous permettre de continuer à tracer un
chemin d'action pour les personnes âgées
le temps imparti étant inversement
proportionnel à l'importance de ce sujet
j'en finis avec trois questions d'abord
vous le savez beaucoup de députés de la
majorité attendent des engagements forts
sur un remboursement lisible de
l'activité physique adaptée au-delà de
l'article 22 suite notamment au rapport
charges et produits de l'Assurance
Maladie pouvez-vous prendre des
engagements sur ce point-là deuxième
question sur les aidents et
troisièmement sur la radiothérapie
merci Madame Mélin pour le groupe
rassemblement national merci Madame la
présidente madamees messieurs les
ministres vos propos se sont voulus
rassurants c'est sans compter avec la
réalité des faits et les conséquences de
votre politique depuis 11 ans déjà dans
la droite ligne d'ailleurs de 40 ans de
destruction de notre système de santé
par une politique
d'austérité toujours plus dans le rabaet
la mauvaise économie et le rabot des
négociations tarifaires toujours à la
baisse alors votre PLFSS 2024 et
spécifiquement votre onâme crée une
austérité mortifère et j'utilise le mot
volontairement car si j'en crois le
dernier rapport très symbolique de la
situation et plus qu'alarmant de la
société française de néonatologie
portant sur les nouveau nés de 1 à 27
jours requérant des soins critiques les
prématurés les accouchements difficiles
et les troubles génétique la situation
est ahurissante l'accueil tout d'ord le
taux moyen d'occupation des lits de de
néonatologie est de 100 % plus de 20 %
du temps la RA se fait donc très souvent
dans les couloirs un/art des services
néonatoau refusent régulièrement des
entrées critiques faute de place ces
lits sont très régul très inégalement
répartis si un minimum requis est de un
lit pour 1000 naissances le ratio dans
le Nord et dans l'Est est de 18 mais il
tombe à 0,8 en ocitanie et 06 en PACA ce
taux est donc manifestement très
insuffisant et cela malgré une baisse de
la natalité de 15 %. nous sommes dans le
comble de la fragilité de nos hôpitaux
les moyens humains ensuite très
insuffisants eux aussi les pédiatres
sont épuisés car pour 80 % d'entre eux
travaillent plus de 50 he et 13 % plus
de 75 he 47 % font plus de 5 gardes à 7
gardes par mois et parfois travaillent
les 4 weekends ainsi la moitié a des
troubles du sommeil où sont en burnout
le résultat en est que 72 % des services
de type 3 voi les vacances d'au moins un
poste et 46 de deux postes et plus quant
aux infirm mière non formé à la
néonologie depuis 2009 ils sont ou elles
sont dans 80 % des établissements au
moins un/ers peu expérimenté peut former
la fidélisation est donc difficile et
les équipes instables ainsi il règne un
sous-effectif sur plus de 70 % des jours
d'hospitalisation bien évidemment tout
ça se rajoute à ce tableau cblé toutes
les difficultés chroniques de
fonctionnement des hôpitaux des
maternités ça nous connaissons bien au
total la situation est alarmante la
mortalité du premier mois dans notre
pays a globalement augmenté depuis 10
ans en concentrant sur cette zone d'âge
74 % des décès nous parlons de décès
d'enfants mes chers collègues si vous
permettez alors qu'elle n'était que de
65 % en 2005 et serait ce serait selon
ce rapport tenez-vous bien 1200 décès de
nouveau né qui pourrai ou qui aurait dû
être évité et cela par rapport à une
moyenne européenne nous faisant passer
de la 3e position des pays à faible
mortalité à la 20e place l'âge plus
avancé des primos parturiante ou
l'augmentation des grossesses multiples
n'explique pas tout c'est bien l'état
général de nos hôpitaux et de nos
maternités qui est en cause on ne peut
plus gérer la santé par le Rabet les
déficits et les dettes il faut donc
changer de focus et gérer les comptes de
la Sécurité sociale au N et non de les
laisser filer et avoir une politique
familiale une politique de l'emploi et
de la santé porté par une réelle
stratégie ainsi qu'une réelle volonté
politique alors ma question à tous les
trois est la suivante quand consz-vous
inverser votre stratégie si vous en avez
une je vous
remercie monsieur modé pour la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente
madames messieurs les ministres chers
collègues nous avons une trajectoire
responsable ça ce sont vos mots monsieur
le ministre de la santé mais quand quand
on regarde la situation dans le pays
quand on regarde ce budget quand on
regarde ce que disent les professionnels
de santé vous êtes complètement à côté
de la réalité en vérité ça fait des
années qu'on entend parler des fameuses
trajectoires responsables et qu'est-ce
qu'elles ont donné ces trajectoires
responsables un affaiblissement de notre
système de santé depuis le covid et un
peu avant la situation elle est
catastrophique on est dans la 7e
puissance mondiale et on a fermé l'accès
aux soins les fermetures d'urgen de
service continu les fermetures
partielles ou totales continu les
fermetures temporaires ou définitives
continues ne serait-ce que sur les deux
dernières semaines je vous donne quatre
exemples à Balé fermeture des urgences
toutes les nuits à châteaugontier sur
Mayenne fermeture des urgences à Lanon
fermeture des urgences 3IS nuits à
guingan fermeture des urgences cette
nuit et la suivante selon le syndicat
SAMU urgence de France il y a un service
sur 2 qui a fermé partiellement ou
totalement cet été dans les services où
c'est encore ouvert les soignants ils
n'en peuvent plus les brancards
s'accumulent on a toutes et tous vu ces
images à perpignant de fil d'attente
pour entrer aux urgences à limoge il y a
certains patients qui ont passé 9 jours
sur des brancards 9 jours aux urgences
et les conséquences de tout cela c'est
une mise en danger de la santé des
Français c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
le syndicat SAMU urgence de France
d'ailleurs l'ancien président de ce
syndicat c'était votre prédécesseur
selon la CGT on a entre 1500 et 2000
personnes qui seraient décédé en un an
faute de prise en charge voilà où elles
nous ont mené les dernières trajectoires
responsables et je pourrais en ajouter
d'autres on pourrait parler de la hausse
des renoncements aux soins on pourrait
parler aussi de la hausse de la
mortalité infantile parce que oui chers
collègues on est un des rares pays
d'Europe où la mortalité infantile
augmente voilà on peut être j'imagine
fier de nous et fier de ces trajectoires
responsables est-ce que vous pouvez dire
aux soignants qui n'en peuvent plus que
cette trajectoire vous proposez elle est
responsable est-ce que vous pouvez dire
aux patients qui attendent des heures
sur des brancards que cette trajectoire
là elle est responsable la vérité c'est
que les Français ils en peuvent plus vos
budgets ils sont tellement responsables
que partout dans le pays il y a une
explosion de la colère dans plusieurs
villes on a vu des manifestations c éit
le cas à guingan c'était le cas à
Saint-Junien en haut de Vienne où il y a
eu des manifestations tout l'été on a vu
à Langre 6000 personnes en manifestation
alors que la commune fait 7600 habitants
à bannière de bigor pareil 3000
personnes en manifestation alors que la
commune fait 7700 habitants et les gens
sont excédés ils sont excédés à tel
point que à quimpère dans l'ARS de
quimpère il y a des gens qui ont qui ont
retenu les les salariés pacifiquement
parce qu'ils en peuvent plus et
qu'est-ce qu'il demandait demandait rien
de miraculeux hein il demandait juste à
avoir accès aux urgences après 15h
rendez-vous compte dans quel état est le
système de santé et là vous nous
proposez un budget mais excusez-moi mais
qui est tout sauf à la hauteur votre
trajectoire elle est elle n'est pas
responsable par contre elle est claire
ce n'est pas un texte pour la santé
c'est un texte pour économiser dans les
textes 100 fois les mots économie une
seule fois hôpital public pour la
Fédération hospitalière de France il
manque 3,5 milliards d'euros et il
dénonce d'ailleurs un budget qui n'est
pas la hauteur pour la caisse
d'Assurance Maladie pareil pour la
première fois félicitation aucun membre
n'a voter pour ce texte pour France asso
santé pareil c'est un texte qui ne
répond pas aux enjeux structurels pour
refonder le système de santé pour la CGT
la CFDT l'UNSA FO la FNI la sneil
Solidaire pareil un texte qui n'est pas
à la hauteur Mutualité Française pareil
les moyens louyer sont sont insuffisants
pour répondre au défis que notre système
de santé doit relever patient soignant
institution tout le monde dénonce ce
budget alors Monsieur le Ministre
question concrète dites-nous combien de
soignants supplémentaires aura-t-on
recruté d'ici la fin de l'année avec ce
budget dites-nous combien de services
pourront rouvrir totalement d'ici la fin
de l'année grâce à ce budget disnous
combien de personnes auront de nouveau
un digne accès à la santé et au soins
grâce à ce budget en vérité ce budget
votre trajectoire elle n'est pas
responsable c'est une trajectoire qui
est technocratique qui est économique
qui est tout sauf responsable et où elle
nous amène c'est vers le crash monsieur
le
ministre monsieur neuder pour le groupe
les républicains merci madame la
présidente Madame et messieurs les
ministres je je vous remercie pour
effectivement avoir organisé un peu
rapidement mais de l'avoir organisé les
réunions interministérielles sur
effectivement des discussions qui sont
un peu analogues à cell du dialogue de
Bery je vais commencer par par la
branche famille et et saluer
effectivement un discours de rupture par
rapport effectivement à votre
prédécesseur puisque je rappelle que
dans le dernier PLFSS la branche famille
était plutôt la variable d'ajustement
avec une relocalisation des 2 milliards
qui avaient été ponctionné pour
contribuer au au déficit et et là
effectivement vous exposez vous l'avez
déjà fait madame la ministre hier soir
vous le refaites aujourd'hui
effectivement un sujet qui nous
préoccupe tous qui est le taux de
natalité en baisse hein qui n'a jamais
été aussi élevé depuis la 2uxème Guerre
mondiale et avec des annonces dont je
voudrais bien effectivement vous
puissiez nous préciser le contour vous
le savez que nous sommes très attachés
les républicains à l'universalité des
des allocations familiales et le revenu
et le la remontée du cocient familial
donc très clairement madame la ministre
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à consentir à
à l'universalité des allocations
familial euh voilà je je ne mets pas en
cause les discussions sur l'attractivité
des personnes personnel les guichets
tout ce qui peut favoriser mais sur la
famille il y a vraiment la question de
l'universalité qui serait vraiment une
rupture concernant la la dépendance et
et et le grand âge je crois que il y a
il y a deux questions je vous l'ai déjà
évoqué hier soir je vais faire le plus
simple c'est la branche autonomie
effectivement je crois qu'il faut revoir
ce sujet-là en y apportant des solutions
de de financement le reste à charge
moyen des familles et globalement de
1000 € pour une personne en épad donc
est-ce que vous env ager des discussions
aussi sur lequel on pourrait travailler
sur des systèmes assuranciels quelle est
votre position pour
financer le le grand âge je rappelle que
par ailleurs sur le le versant
domiciliaire tout ça ne peut être
envisagé que vers un grand plan de
formation puisqu'on a estimé à peu près
à 380000 les acteurs du domicile si on
veut prendre cette transition également
concernant les structures
d'hospitalisation qu'ell soi privée
publi ou du médico-social pardon euh il
y a quand même 3,3 millions de séjours
d'hospitalisation qui ont été reportés
depuis 2020 des retards diagnosti donc
la situation est quand même très
complexe et surtout je voudrais me faire
le porte-parole mais ça l' a été fait
des différentes fédérations
hospitalières de France privé FAP sur
effectivement la la non tenue compte
pour l'instant de de l'inflation avec
1,5 milliards qui ne sont pas de surcout
qui ne sont pour l'instant non financés
donc je vous j'ai entendu vos propos je
temps que vous allez y réfléchir mais il
faut effectivement qu'on puisse préciser
ce point-là puisque on ne peut pas dans
certaines structures se retrouver en
concurrence entre prendre sur le le
budget global et choisir entre le soin
ou ou l'électricité je je je salue la
revalorisation des gardes et des
travails de nuit je voudrais
effectivement et ça a déjà été posé de
je m'excuse je n'ai pas entendu la
réponse donc je vous la repose mes
excuses sur effectivement la
revalorisation des internes qui pose la
question puisque voilà ils sont ils sont
prévu une revalorisation jusqu'à la fin
de l'année est-ce que cette
revalorisation des internes de garde
peut peut être peut être obtenue et et
pérenne et puis je voudrais également
parler également des professionnels
libéraux puisque il faut reprendre ces
ces ces discussions on ne peut pas
rester avec ces ces mesures insultantes
de 1,50 € de revalorisation des
consultation et attirer l'attention sur
l'absence de revarisation depuis
2009 des professionnels paramédicaux
notamment des des infirmiers des acteurs
du domicile qui font qui font face à des
à des augmentations de consommation
d'essens de gazoil avec des prix bloqués
depuis 2009 enfin je finirai sur la
prévention mais non je ne finirai pas
parce que mon temps est épuisé merci
Monsieur Nadar monsieur turquis pour le
groupe
démocrate merci madame la présidente
Madame et messieurs les ministres chers
collègues merci merci de ces
présentations clair et détaillé le
groupe démocrate se félicite de
l'ambition de ce projet de loi et des
moyens consacrés au renforcement de
notre modèle social son haut niveau de
redistribution et de protection contre
les risques de la vie est au cœur de
notre République au cœur du consentement
de chacune et chacun des assurés au
vivre ensemble parmi les nombreuses
mesures des 40 articles du texte je
souhaite vous interroger sur trois
points en particulier la prévention la
solidarité à la source et la lutte
contre la fraude concernant la
prévention véritable fil rouge du projet
de loi nous saluons les avancées
concrètes à court comme un moyen terme
pour améliorer la santé de nos
concitoyens je pense à la campagne de
vaccination contre le papill
papillomavirus à la gratuité des
préservatifs pour les moins de 26 ans ou
à la prise en charge à 60 % par la
Sécurité sociale des protections
hygiéniques
réutilisables la prévention constitue
une responsabilité collective majeure à
laquelle la puissance publique prend
toute sa part mais elle est également
l'affaire de toutes et tous pour que
nous soyons individuellement en tant
qu'assuré actif dans la gestion du
risque c'est l'objet des rendez-vous
prévention aux âes clés de la vie que
l'article 20 va contribuer à
généraliser par la sensibilisation par
l'appropriation des bonnes pratiques par
la lutte contre les inégalités sociales
cet article renforce les fondations de
l'édifice de la prévention que cette
majorité construit depuis 6 ans c'est
tout l'honneur de l'action publique que
de préparer l'avenir des générations qui
nous succéderont et bénéficieront de
Tell mesures aussi le groupe démocrate
attire votre attention sur le sujet de
la santé mentale et notamment celle des
jeunes comment le gouvernement compte-il
agir face à cet enjeu au cours des
prochaines années sur la santé mentale
spécifiquement et plus largement sur le
thème de la prévention notre groupe
proposa des enrichissements au texte par
voie d'amendement plusieurs amendements
sont issus du travail de notre collègue
Cyril Isaac sibil qui a élaboré une
feuille de route sur la prévention en
santé car nous regrettons l'absence de
mesures significatives sur les
consommations d'alcool de sucre ou de
tabac déterminant majeurs en terme de
santé concernant la solidarité à la
source sorte de pendant au prélèvement à
la source le projet de loi comporte de
premières avancées et c'est une
excellente chose par exemple à l'article
21 avec l'extension simplifiée de la
complémentaire santé solidairire pour de
nouveaux allocataires de minimas sociaux
au-delà des premières expérimentations
en cours pour la solidarité à la source
auriez-vous à nous présenter madame la
ministre un calendrier de mise en œuvre
de cette solidarité tant attendue
Solidar et à la source tant
attendue enfin ce projet de loi comporte
aussi plusieurs dispositions nécessaires
à la lutte contre la fraude qui abîme
notre contrat social l'action sociale ne
se réduit bien sûr pas à une surenchère
de nouvelles dépenses pour mener à bien
les politiques de la nation en matière
de santé et de solidarité nous nous nous
devons aussi de générer de nouvelles
recettes ou à minima de limiter les
dépenses
indues monsieur le ministre des comptes
publics pouvez-vous nous détailler la
manière dont le Conseil d'évaluation des
fraudes nouvellement créées permettra
d'aller plus loin dans la lutte contre
la faute fiscale et sociale enfin en
cohérence avec les politique de
prévention évoqué précédemment
pensez-vous et la question est
collective nécessaire d'aller vers un
financement pluriannuel en matière de
santé et de sécurité sociale c'est une
demande forte d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs pour avoir davantage de
lisibilité et de visibilité le groupe
démocrate votera résolument en faveur de
ce projet de
loi merci Monsieur Gad pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente
madamees messieurs les ministres d'abord
une petite remarque de forme il y a un
an au moment de l'adoption par 493 du
PLFSS la première ministre vous étiez
dans un autre rôle monsieur le ministre
dirigeant son cabinet s'était offusqué
de la position en disant mais c'est pas
normal que vous votiez contre ce PLFSS
euh et
on nous disait que il aurait dû être et
pu être coconstruit et dans la foulée
monsieur Bron avait pris l'engagement
pour le PLFSS suivant d'intensifier ce
travail de coproduction avec les
parlementaires la réalité c'est qu'il
n'a pas eu lieu vous avez fait les
comptes de Ségure com ptes on nous a mis
sur la table les mesures qui étaient
déjà arbitrées mais à aucun moment vous
pourrez cette fois-ci nous raconter le
compte
cte d'une association des parlementaires
alors c'est mieux ces comptes de séure
mais si on pouvait je vous le dit tout
de suite l'année prochaine travailler
sur le PLFSS qu'il s'agisse des mesures
en chiffres c'est peut-être plus
compliqué mais notamment des mesures en
lettres en amont en associant les
parlementaires de la commission des
affaires sociales je pense que ce serait
utile alors on peut comprendre pourquoi
cet exercice ne se fait pas parce que il
y a des postulats forts qui se retrouve
à travers les affectations de moyens qui
cette année encore ne vous permettront
pas de répondre à l'empleur des besoins
et l'année dernière nous avions
tellement raison que ceux des
amendements qui proposaient pour le
PLFSS 2023 de compléter les crédits dont
nous savions d'emblé qu'ils étaient
insuffisants et bien vous les
introduisez dans les mesures
rectificatives de 2000 pour 2023 dans
les premiers articles c'est bien la
preuve que les alertes que nous vous
faisons pour l'année à venir vous les
confirmez
malheureusement avec beaucoup trop de
retard si on pouvait procéder
différemment donc un nonâ notoirement
insuffisant qui ne règlera pas la crise
du financement et pire des lignes rouges
qui vont être problématiques monsieur le
ministre lors des comptes de Ségure vous
nous avez dit la question de la
responsabilisation et donc des la
participation forfaitaire par
consultation et la franchise médicale ne
figure pas en tant que tel mais elle est
dans la trajectoire elle donc elle
pourrait être dans le débat au moment où
nous allons débuter il est important
pour nous qu'une fois pour toute vous
nous disiez qu'est-ce que vous avez
envie de faire qu'est-ce qui est prévu
qu'est-ce que vous mettrez dans des
mesures décrétales ou réglementaires
parce qu'il y a quand même un énorme
paradoxe de nous dire c'est dans la
trajectoire sans savoir si vous
doublez la participation forfaitaire ou
le montant des franchises et si vous
maintenez le même plafond je pense qu'il
est temps j'espère j'ose espérer que les
arbitrages ont été pris le contraire
serait inquiétant les autres lignes
rouges ont déjà été mentionné la
limitation des arrêts de travail le
malus sur le remboursement des frais de
transport la contribution des régimes de
retraite complémentaires et tant
d'autres dans les 50 secondes qui me
reste je vous dit que j'aurais aussi
aimé vous parler des deux béances celle
sur l'hôpital avec quand même
pardonnez-moi l'expression une forme de
coitus interruptus par rapport aux
annonces de d'Emmanuel Macron c'était en
Nesson dans les vœux la population de
santé en disant cette fois-ci nous
allons réformer la T2A dans le mandat
précédent j'avais dit que je le ferais
progressivement là je vais y aller de
manière massive la réalité c'est qu'il y
a rien de significatif si ce n'est un
engagement qui demeure extrêmement
extrêmement timide et l'autre béance
c'est bien évidemment la question de la
branche autonomie et comme il me reste
peu de temps moi je veux devant
l'ensemble des membres de la comm
sociale parce qu'on VO bien que la
trajectoire même avec les 2 milliards
qui ont été rajouté ne permet pas
d'avoir une visibilité sur ce qui va se
faire poser la question madame la
ministre est-ce que vous allez accepter
la proposition votée à l'unanimité par
les parlementaires dans la loi PPL bien
vieillir d'avoir une loi de
programmation sur le grand âge et est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire ici oui il y
aura en 2024 une loi de programmation
sur le grand âge merci Monsieur Gernigon
pour le groupe
auaison merci madame la Présidente
madames et messieurs les ministres
madame la rapporteur générale chers
collègues le budget de la Sécurité
sociale est le reflet de de notre
engagement collectif envers la santé les
familles l'autonomie et notre système de
retraite par répartition nous avons au
fil des ans et particulièrement pendant
la crise sanitaire démontrer notre
capacité à mobiliser des ressources
considérables pour protéger notre nation
et notre système de santé en tant que
législateur notre responsabilité est
d'assurer la pérennité de ce modèle
social en poursuivant la transformation
du système et en continuant de bâtir sa
résilience et sa soutenabilité
au service de la santé de chacun et de N
solidarité collective c'est ce à quoi
s'attache ce texte et je m'en réjouis la
première raison d'être positif à l'ordre
d'entamer nos discussions tient à
l'amélioration de la trajectoire
financière de la sécurité sociale depuis
2 ans grâce à la politique ambitieuse
menée par le
gouvernement après des déficites
historiques près de 40 milliards d'euros
en 2020 le solde des régimes
obligatoires de base et du fond de
solidarité vie
s'est nettement redressé de 2021 à 2023
sous l'effet de la reprise économique et
des créations d'emplois il devrait
atteindre un peu plus de 11 milliards
d'euros en
2024 ce PLFSS est également un jalon
important pour renforcer la
soutenabilité et l'acceptabilité de
notre modèle social en 2024 pour tenir
cet objectif londam connaît une hausse
de 3,2 % tout en prévoyant ,5 milliards
d'euros d'économie qui passe notamment
par un effort de maîtrise des dépenses
de soins de ville et par une
responsabilisation de l'ensemble des
acteurs l'accent mis sur la prévention
en santé doit permettre de poursuivre
cette dynamique notre groupe horizon et
apparenté reste fidèle à sa ligne de
sérieux budgétaire nous proposerons des
amendements qui tiennent compte d'un
contexte de finances publiques
contraintte dans une logique de
transparence de santé publique et de
justice
social nous souhaitons que ce PLFSS soit
l'occasion dans un contexte favorable à
un an des Jeux Olympiques 2024 d'avancer
sur le remboursement du sport sur
ordonnance sport santé pour les patients
souffrant du diabète ou du cancer
conformément au rapport annuel de
l'assurance maladie dont c'est une
recommandation pour ces deux pathologies
les bienfaits sur la santé et
l'évolution de ces maladies chroniques
sont désormais démontrés mais le coût de
la pratique sportive peut néanmoins
rester un frein pour ces
patients d'autre part nous souhaiterions
vous interroger monsieur le ministre sur
l'opportunité d'une programmation
pluriannuelle des financements en santé
qui répond à plusieurs enjeux pour nos
citoyens
elle donnerait de la clarté et de la
visibilité à l'ensemble des acteurs de
santé pour 5 années de son application
et permet une cohérence des budget avec
les besoins de santé de la population à
l'échelle
territoriale aussi elle oriente les
évolutions du système de santé vers la
prévention en santé et permet de
préparer notre système de soins à la
prise en charge de pathologie complexe
et nouvell concernant un autre enjeu de
santé publique entre 10 et 20 % des
nouvelles mères sont touché par la
dépression postpartum un véritable sujet
de santé mentale pour les femmes dans
notre pays un diagnostic et un
traitement de process sont cruciaux pour
prévenir la la pardon et la dépression
et améliorer les résultats du traitement
nous proposons la création d'un parcours
de soins dédiés implémenté par toutes
les ARS en impliquant tous les
professionnels de santé concernés est
proposé pour assurer une détection et un
traitement précoce et pour renforcer
l'information disponible pour les
professionnels et les
familles enfin pour continuer de libérer
du temps médical nous proposons que la
signature des certificats de décès
actuellement autorisé par des médecins
actifs ou retess
merci Monsieur gerig monsieur PAVI pour
le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
madamees messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues le gouvernement soumet
aujourd'hui à l'approbation du Parlement
le budget de la Sécurité sociale pour
2024 une fois n'est pas coutume
commençons par saluer ce qu'il y a de
positif dans le PLFSS que vous présentez
aujourd'hui la gratuité des préserv et
des protections menstruelles pour les
moins de 26 ans le lancement d'une
campagne nationale de vaccination contre
les papiavirus dès la 5e l'évolution du
financement des épades par la fusion des
sections soins et dépendan ou encore les
prémisses de la transition écologiques
des établissements de santé disons-le
dès que vos mesures iront dans le bon
sens nous les soutiendrons mais cela ne
nous empêchera pas évidemment de vouloir
les améliorer sur la gratuité des
protections menstruelles et des
préservatifs pourquoi se limiter à 26
ans quand il s'agit avant tout d'une
question de santé publique mais soyons
clair le groupe écologiste ne pourra pas
soutenir le cadre dans lequel s'inscrit
ce PLFSS car ce sapoudrage de mesures
dilué dans quelques articles n'est pas
suffisant pour cacher le verrouillage
des dépenses de santé par le
cantonnement des dépenses sous 22 % du
PIB jusqu'en 202 ni l'AM ni les
sousendames n'échapperont donc à votre
logique austéritaire de maîtrise des
dépenses au-delà de l'insuffisance vient
pour nous des doutes sérieux quant à la
sincérité des budgets qui nous sont
présentés aujourd'hui de pfss en pfss en
raison de sa surexécution londam n'a de
cesse d'être rectifié l' l'exemple de
londam hospitalier pour 2023 est
frappant de 100,7 milliards en LFSS 23
il est passé à 101,3 milliards en avril
dernier pour finalement atteindre
102,5 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui nous
atteignons ainsi un différentiel total
de 1,8 milliards d'euros comment les
hôpitaux peuvent-ils durablement prévoir
leur trajectoire financière avec un tel
rafistolage budgétaire si les
rectifications enchaînent de l'ondame 23
interroge l'ondame 24 nous alarme
davantage alors que la Fédération
hospitalière de France pointe un
abonnement nécessaire de 2 milliards
supplémentaires pour couvrir les besoins
de cette année l'ONDAM hospitalier pour
2024 n'évolue qu'à 3 2 % votre scénario
macroéconomique est certes plausible
selon le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques mais votre scénario de
croissance est quant à lui bien
optimiste votre prévision d'inflation
présente un risque de dépassement risque
à prendre encore davantage en
considération avec la nouvelle envolée
des prix du pétrole et le risque de
dépassement des dépenses de santé est
avéré monsieur le ministre pourquoi
s'obstiner à présenter un budget de la
Sécurité sociale qui sous-évalue les
besoins pour couvrir l'inflation et les
dépenses d'investissement la réponse est
simple pour maîtriser la dépense mais en
réalité à quel prix celui de futur
rectification pour l'année en cours qui
plongeront à nouveau notre système de
soins dans l'incertitude et la
contrainte financière c'est ajouté de la
crise sur la crise dans ce cadre tout
est tracé tout tracé de l'austérité
budgétaire ni ce PLFSS ni les prochains
et ce jusqu'en 2027 ne seront à même de
transformer structurellement notre
système de soins pour répondre aux
enjeux sociaux et environnementaux qui
se posent dès aujourd'hui avec cette
logique d'enveloppe armé nous ne pouvons
être d'accord ce cadre là où chaque
mesure de progrès s'accompagne d'une
mesure d'économie nous le rejetons vous
osez AINS lencer la chasse aux arrêts
maladies désormais seule porte de sortie
pour les Français en souffrance au
travail après votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage et des retraite et
en doublant la franchise des médicaments
vous faites peser sur les Français la
pénurie des médicaments tout en arrosant
d'argent public les industriels
pharmaceutique D qui délocalise à
l'étranger et ce par pure logique de
profit l'effondrement climatique a
commencé l'année 2023 sera probablement
l'année la plus chaude jamais connue les
restos du cœur ne sont plus en capacité
de fornir l'aide alimentaire au plus
fragile les maladies chroniques
explosent et frappent d'abord les plus
précaires et quelle est votre réponse au
12 millions de personnes atteintes
d'affection longue durée il faut
maîtriser la dépense et à cela nous ne
pouvons souscrire monsieur d'ville pour
le groupe
GDR merci
Madame merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre messieurs
les ministres quelle nouvell recette
prévoyez-vous pour financer nos
retraites notre santé notre protection
sociale vous dites que le déficit se
résorbe mais à quel prix social à quel
prix de santé la réforme des retraites
était censée en finir avec le déficit et
la dette votre budget nous confirme
qu'il n'en est rien en revanche les
salariés commencent à la sentir passer
voyant la date de leur liquidation de
pension reculer nous espérions un PLFSS
venant rectifier le PLFSS rectificatif
antisocial et antiém démocratique du
printemps l'objectif national de
dépenses d'assurance maladie comprinse
chaque année les dépenses de santé 3,2
c'est en dessous de l'augmentation
tendantielle vous risquez même au bout
du compte d'être en dessous de
l'inflation générale l'année qui vient
de s'écouler vient de montrer la
fragilité des estimation gouvernemental
en la matière l'objectif est donc
d'autant plus irréaliste que notre
système de santé est sous tension et que
depuis des années on lui demande de
faire toujours plus d'économie cela aura
des conséquences sur les professionnels
les établissements de santé et les
patients on a le sentiment que vous ne
voulez toujours pas voir une réalité
incontournable l'hôpital public est en
crise non ça ne va pas mieux et le
gouvernement prévoit 500 millions
d'euros d'économie à l'hôpital au nom de
l'efficience il y a besoin d'ouvrir des
négociations salariales globales et d'en
finir avec la politique du saupoudrage
de prime la précarité la
sous-reconnaissance des métiers les
sous-effectifs et cetera au passage
aucune mesure n'est annoncé sur la santé
mentale malgré l'échec du dispositif
monpsy alors qu'il y a besoin
d'embaucher massivement des psychologues
dans service public le volume de soins
délivré à l'hôpital n'a toujours pas
retrouvé son niveau de 2019 il faut
lutter contre le défaut de soins le
renoncement au soins les ruptures de
parcours la tarification à l'activité
passera de 54 à 49 % en 2026 on est donc
loin d'une véritable remise en question
vous annoncez des mesures dites de
responsabilisation il s'agit notamment
de la modification du ticket modérateur
pour les soins dentaires avec un
financement par la cotisation mutualiste
il s'agit d'un doublement des franchises
médicales le confirmez-vous
on demande aux assurés de financer
eux-mêmes leurs soins en réalité vivent
la sécurité sociale pendant ce temps
c'est open bar pour les exonérations de
cotisation exonération de cotisation
pour les multinationales d'un côté et
hold up dans les cotisations de l'Unedic
et de laagir Carco qui appartiennent au
salariés faut-il le rappeler vous voulez
en réalité empêcher la revalorisation
des pensions complémentaires en période
de forte inflation pendant ce temps on
ne lutte pas assez non plus contre la
marchandisation c'est le cas en matière
de médicament et ce n'est pas une
garantie contre les pénuries la branche
autonomie connaî une augmentation de son
financement mais nous attendons toujours
les mesures fortes et cohérentes
garantissant de nouveaux droits la
création de postes ne va pas ez loin et
pas assez vite pour les épades et
l'accompagnement à domicile c'est de
déployer un service public puissant dont
nous avons besoin la branche ATMP
demeure excédentaire sans que l'on
décide de s'attaquer beaucoup plus
fortement à la sous-déclaration à la
sous-reconnaissance et aux mauvaises
conditions de travail davantage ce PLFSS
réforme la reconnaissance de la faute
inexcusable de l'employeur en barémisant
l'indemnisation on sait ce qu'il en a
été des barem pour les licenciements et
en plus sans s'interroger sur leurs
cause vous instaureer une restriction
des arrêtsmadies avec une refonte du
contrôle de l'arrêt maladie qui donne
pouvoir de suspension au médecin
diligenté par l'employeur qui limite à 3
jours la durée des arrêts de travail dé
livré en téléconsultation alors même
qu'il est de plus en plus difficile
d'avoir un médecin traitant il faut
arrêter de rouler toujours sur la même
pente changer de
logiciel monsieur panifous pour le
groupe
luute merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs les ministres ministre madames
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues le projetcement de la sécurité
sociale qui nous est présenté dans une
période de forte inflation est porté par
une volonté d'économie plus que de
réelle transition que ce soit dans nos
hôpitaux ou dans nos épades dans la
santé en général chacun s'accorde sur la
nécessité de réinvestir ces secteurs
financièrement et humainement avec le
groupe lot nous souhaitons que la santé
devienne une priorité nationale il ne
s'agit pas de critiquer le fait de
chercher à équilibrer le budget des
comptes sociaux particulièrement après
la crise sanire qui les a fragilisé mais
de dire que ces économies se font là où
de notre point de vue il n'en faudrait
pas je pense par exemple à la limitation
des arrêts de travail à l'augmentation
du ticket modérateur pour les soins
nantaires qu'en est-il également de
votre volonté d'augmenter les franchises
sur les médicaments et les consultations
qui pénaliseront les assurés les plus
modestes les complémentaires santé
menanent d'ailleurs déjà d'augmenter
leurs tarifs je pense aussi à la
ponction que vous souhaitez faire sur
laagir Arco à laquelle nous sommes
opposés je crois que notre système de
protection sociale mérite mieux que de
simples économies il a besoin aussi de
nouvelles ressources notre système a
besoin de nouvelles ressources car il
est en difficulté depuis plusieurs
années et que les besoins à venir sont
croissants sur l'accès aux soins il
suffit de regarder la situation des
établissements de santé l'OND dame 2023
et 2024 ne permettent pas de couvrir
l'inflation et les revalorisations
salariales du mois de juin sur les
territoires insulaires et ultramarins
confrontés à des surcût structurel nous
ne pouvons plus repousser sans cesse la
revalorisation des coefficients
géographiques sur le soutien à
l'autonomie qui était pourtant affiché
comme une priorité le compte n'y est pas
non plus le transfert d'une fraction de
la CSG à la CNSA pour 2024 ne
représentera que 2,6 milliards d'euros
quand tous les rapports sur ce sujet
fixent les besoins à près de 8 milliards
nous appelons à la mise en place d'une
contribution spécifique via une
augmentation de la CG sur le capital ou
bien une contribution sur les donations
et successions les plus élevées par
exemple je veux également insister sur
les métiers combien de postes ont
effectivement été financés sur les 3000
budgetés en 2023 pour les éepads et
comment allez-vous tenir la trajectoire
des 50000 d'ici 2027 alors que vous
annoncez pour 2024 seulement pardon 6000
et TP c'est toujours moins qu'un poste
par établissement le signal n'est pas
bon les difficultés de recrutement ne
sont pas du seulement à la quantité des
personnes formées mais aussi beaucoup
aux conditions de travail dans nos
établissements au ratio d'encadrement
trop faible la volonté du gouvernement
de créer 50000 postes en EPAD est une
excellente mesure l'ouverture concrète
de ces postes d'ici à 3 contribuerit à
redonner une image positive de ces
métiers à améliorer leur attractivité à
faire revenir celles et ceux si nombreux
qui l'ont quitté pour des raison plus de
condition de travail que de rémunération
notre groupe rejoint la volonté de
revoir le modèle des tarification des
épades un modèle aujourd'hui inutilement
complexe et qui génère aussi des
inégalités territoriales néanmoins sur
la fusion des sections soins et
dépendances une double expérimentation
permettrait de de déterminer qui des
départements ou des ARS sont les plus à
même de piloter cette nouvelle section
et non seulement les ARS comme c'est le
cas dans ce projet de loi nous
souhaitons souligner deux mesures
positives sur ce texte d'abord un volet
intéressant sur la prévention et la
lutte contre le nonreours que nous
souhaiterions d'ailleurs voir élargi aux
plus jeunes au plus précaires aux
bénéficiaires de tous les minimas
sociaux ensuite sur le remboursement des
prostections menstruelles réutilisables
notre groupe défendra plutôt un accès
gratuit à toutes les femmes de toutes
les protections périodiques c'est un
Angé d'égalité et de santé publique je
terminerai sur deux grands Absen de ce
texte pas de réell mesures fortte sur la
lutte contre la désertification médicale
ni sur la santé mentale qui demeure le
parent pauvre de notre politique de
santé je vous
remercie merci mesdames et Messieurs les
orateurs de groupe je vais maintenant
passer la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances monsieur lausanna pour 2
minutes merci madame la Présidente
madames et Messieurs les ministre chers
collègues je vous remercie de
m'accueillir au sein de votre commission
aujourd'hui et nous examinerons le P FSS
pour avis mercredi prochain donc en
commission des finances tout d'abord je
constate avec satisfaction que le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques a estimé
plausible et vraisembla les principales
hypothèses macro-économiques sur
lesquelles reposent les textes
budgétaires de cette autonne cela
démontre que la politique économique et
de l'emploi conduite ces dernières
années par le gouvernement s'est révélé
d'une grande efficacité le PLFSS pour
2024 porte une véritable ambition pour
notre de protection sociale tout en
prévoyant plusieurs mesures visant à
renforcer la pertinence de la dépense
publique ce texte est ambitieux
puisqu'il consacre la poursuite d'un
effort important en matière d'accès aux
soins et de prévention par exemple le
lancement de la campagne de vaccination
contre les infections en papilloma virus
humain et aussi de déployer plus
largement les bilans de prévention au
différents âges de la vie je porterai
d'ailleurs un amendement pour adapter
ces rendez-vous deuxè chose le PLF c est
également ambitieux en matière de
modernisation de notre système de santé
notamment la mesure visant à
rééquilibrer le financement des
établissement de santé en augmentant la
part de ses ressources reposant sur des
dotations sur objectifs de santé
publique et indicateurs de qualité enfin
si l'ONDAM qui est un objectif je le
rappelle connait une hausse de 3,2 % il
est supérieur à l'inflation le PLF
prévoit par ailleurs un total de 3,5
milliards d'euros d'économie en
particulier
par la lutte contre la fraude et la
pertinence des soins enfin Monsieur le
Ministre un jour nous devrions peut-être
dépasser la vision de l'annualité pour
savoir ce que nous voulons que devient
notre santé du futur merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur je vais
maintenant donner la parole au ministre
et commencer par Monsieur kenav pour lui
permettre de partir ensuite au Sénat
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
peut-être juste deux trois deux trois
compléments ou ou réponse à des
questions qui t à les rassembler sur
notamment les interventions sur
l'austérité j'ai entendu des mots
terrible sur l'austérité mortifère
l'austérité je la lis je vous l'entends
dans vos interventions mais je la vois
pas dans mes comptes je suis désolé de
vous le dire euh quand on a comme nous
euh cette année 5 % de déficit public
3000 milliards de dettes qu'on a encore
un N d'â qui va progresser plus vite que
l'inflation nous ne sommes pas dans un
régime d'austérité non je suis désolé de
de vous le dire et honnêtement il faut
aussi se poser la question de manière
raisonnable sur l'efficience de la
dépense ce n'est pas un gros mot
l'efficience de la dépense les
contraintes financières existent et je
crois que tous les problèmes que vous
avez évoqué ne ne trouvve pas
nécessairement de solutions dans des
moyens supplémentaires donc
permettez-moi de vous dire que non et à
la fois ce projet et le projet loi de
finance ne sont pas des budgets
d'austérité sur la question de la
pluriannualité il y a un très bon texte
pour ça qui donne une vision
pluri-annuelle y compris sur le fin
financement de notre système de santé de
notre sécurité sociale c'est la loi de
programmation sur les finances publiques
mais oui mais bien sûr je vous rappelle
un certain nombre d'articles un certain
je vous réponds je vous réponds l'AM
l'évolution de l'ONDAM vous l'avez dans
la loi de programmation sur les finances
publiques l'évolution des des régimes de
base et du fond de solidarité vis vous
l'avez dans lare programme sur les
finances publiques vous avez la
déclinaison par sousobjectif donc il y a
déjà énormément de choses c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est beaucoup accroché pardon de
le dire au fait qu'on ait une loi de
programmation sur les finances publiques
parce que ça répond à beaucoup de vos
interrogations oui il faut qu'on se
projette sur le temps long et notamment
avec ce type de texte c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous sommes tant attachés
sur le le Conseil d'évaluation de de la
fraude nous avons acté un certain nombre
de un certain nombre de de travaux il y
a des sujets sur lequels nous avons
vraiment des des des comment dirais-je
des des des zones un peu inexplorées sur
la frodte je pense ça nous concerne un
peu moins ici en commission des affaires
sociales mais sur l'impôt sur le revenu
sur l'impôt sur les sociétés on a quand
même exploré et on va aller beaucoup
plus loin sur et là ça vous concerne et
ça nous concerne plus directement les
dépenses d'assurance maladie donc on a
choisi un certain nombre de sujets sur
lesquels il nous faut partager y compris
avec vous une évaluation beaucoup plus
robuste de la réalité de la Frode pour
ensuite vérifier si nos politiques de
lutte contre la faute sont efficaces si
elles ne sont pas est-ce qu'il faut les
compléter comme on le fait dans ce PLF
et euh PLFSS et enfin je voudrais redire
à monsieur panifou qui qui évoque la
question de la ponction sur l'agir
Carco nous ne prenons pas nous ne
prenons pas les excédents accumulés de
l'agir Carco grâce à la bonne gestion
par les partenaires sociaux nous disons
juste une je vais le redire même si je
pense vous avez très bien compris ce que
j'avais dit mais je vais quand même
redire que il y a un impact de cette
réforme des retraites que nous étions
parfois un peu seul à porter qui un
impact sur le régime qui n'était pas le
fémisme vous avez vu le fémisme qui
n'était pas nécessairement attendu tout
on l' voilà on l'a porté elle a un
impact direct sur le régime agir Carco
et nous on dit cette réforme pourquoi on
l'a faite aussi pour garantir
l'équilibre financier sur le long terme
de nos régimes donc il est légitime que
cet impact d'une réforme que plupart ne
voulait pas autour de nous on dis c'est
ben elle contribue à à l'équilibre de
nos finances publiques rejet mais on
laisse il est hors de question qu'on
prenne les excédents du régime voilà
donc c'est pardon mais il faut quand
même rentrer dans le détail pour éviter
effectivement de caricaturer un peu
l'intention qui est la nottre en matière
de de relation avec laag Carco je vous
confirme que les discussions continuent
je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
peut-être quelques remarques
transversales sur des questions qui sont
revenues chez chez plusieurs dans
plusieurs interventions puis après je
vais essayer d'être d'être plus
exhaustif dans le droitfil de ce que
vient de dire Thomas casaznav il y a des
moments dans dans dans les expressions
où j'ai le sentiment qu'on qu'on que le
le principe même de construction de de
long d'AM par rapport au budget de
l'État est oublié en fait tout ce qui
qui est exécuté à l'année n-1 est pris
en base à l'année N et donc on parle
bien d'une progression sur la base de là
où on aura atterri à la fin de l'année
donc le le le la démonstration
d'austérité me semble un tout petit peu
difficile à à conduire jusqu'à son terme
deuxièmement j'avoue et je le dis très
clairement euh à certains notamment à
Madame Mélin que le côté vous restez les
bras ballants face à la situation de
l'hôpital la réponse elle est simple les
mesures du du Ségure de la santé sur le
le personnel paramédical et médical les
mesures que la première ministre a
annoncé sur le travail de nuit quand on
parle de 435 € en moyenne pour une
infirmière en fin de carrière qui fait
qui travaille la nuit je suis désolé de
vous dire que je ne pense pas que que ce
soit 435 € mensuels que ce soit rien du
tout et du coup derrière chaque lit
rouvert grâce à ça et c'est ce qui est
en train de se passer chaque lit rouvert
grâce à ça est une victoire parce que
derrière madame je prends je prends
évidemment le point
aujourd'hui de très nombreux services
ont des postes vacants on des postes
vacants qui ne sont pas vacants pour des
raisons budgétaires ils sont vacants
pour des raisons d'attractivité pour des
raisons de démographie médicale et sauf
à basculer dans un système qui est assez
différent mais qu'on pourrait discuter
un instant de raison qui consisterait à
intégralement nationaliser le la
médecine mais même chez les praticiens
hospitaliers publics le le choix et et
du côté de ceux qui de ceux qui de de
c'est de leur côté donc non on ne fait
pas rien pour l'hôpital la l'Assistance
publique hôpitaux de Paris rouvrira 400
lit d'ici la fin de l'année 400 lit on a
les plus grosses campagnes de
recrutement qu'on a faite j'espère qu'on
sera autour de 1000 ou 1500 lit qui
auront été ouverts d'ici la fin de
l'année et pour moi c'est quelque chose
c'est c'est c'est il y a 380000 lit
d'hospitalisation en France je ne vous
parle pas d'une révolution je vous parle
d'un de de quelque chose où on arrête
d'être sur le toboggan dans lequel on a
collectivement et et je me mets dedans
le sentiment d'être dans dans cette
situation vous avez employé vous avez
employé vous avez employé monsieur vous
avez employé minist monsieur le député
mod je reviendrai je reviendrai madame
sur votre intervention plus précisément
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué
notamment la néonatologie sujet central
sur lequel je reviendrai vous avez
évoqué monsieur le député modé
l'effondrement du système de soins
excuse excusez-moi mais si les mot ont
un sens l'effondrement du système de
soin je ne suis et le gouvernement n'est
dans aucun dénis sur la situation de
tenstion dans l'hôpital public on a dans
ce pays c'est exceptionnel la densité
par ailleurs et c'est une chante 680
services d'urgence il y en a cinq qui
ont été entièrement fermés pendant l'été
il y en a alors SAMU urgence de France
comme vous l'indiquez par ailleurs qui
est un syndicat peut indiquer qu'il y en
a 200 ou 250 nous nous on n pas
exactement les mêmes manières de chiffré
mais peu importe il est évident que de
très nombreux services d'urgence ont été
touchés cet été par l'impossibilité de
tenir la totalité des lignes de garde et
notamment de tenir la nuit mais moi ma
première responsabilité ma première
responsabilité c'est que un un une
personne qui aille se faire soigner dans
un hôpital je sois sûr que la ligne de
garde elle est tenue et que aucune des
personnes dans cette salle parce que je
je je on ne ferme jamais un service pour
des raisons financières mais par contre
je je dois dire que je ne laisserai
jamais un service ouvert dans lequel je
n'amènerai aucun de mes trois enfants se
faire soigner si jamais il y avait un
problème or aujourd'hui quand on a une
ligne de garde qui n'est pas tenue et
ben la responsabilité ma responsabilité
celle du DG de la RS celle du directeur
de l'hôpital c'est de mettre en place
notre système pour que ce service soit
tenu c'est ce qui a été fait avec la
régulation par le 15 et quand j'entends
les chiffres qui ont été mentionnés par
certains syndicats de 1500 à 2000
personnes décédées excusez-moi de dire
je considère que ces chiffres sont une
honte sont une honte aujourd'hui les
soignants évidemment on ne doit pas
compter sur leur héroïsme et moi je ne
compte pas sur leur héroïsme la seule
chose que je que je pense nécessaire de
faire c'est de les rémunérer comme il se
doit les les les augmentations de
rémunération elles ont été euh inédites
au cours des trois dernières années mais
surtout c'est de leur de redonner le
sens et ceux qui veulent le faire c'est
du soin mais par contre parce que il
faut aller il faut lire le rapport de
Sam urgence de France dans sa totalité
si vous voulez aller jusqu'au bout de la
logique consistant notamment à fermer
toute une série de petits servic
d'urgence pour concentrer sur les gros
services d'urgence je je ouvrons la
discussion ouvrons la discussion je
pense que la régulation n'est pas une
situation satisfaisante par rapport à ce
que nous avons connu mais je pense que
le le mais je pense que si euh on reste
dans quelque chose de binaire qui
consiste à dire soit on a tous les
professionnels soit on ferme et ben
évidemment on va on va aller dans une
situation où il y a des hôpitaux où on
narrivera pas à tenir malgré les le
malgré tout l'investissement financier
qu'on pourra mettre le et vous avez cité
la manifestation et prenant ça pour un
acte de résistance quand on quand on
quand non non pardon monsieur quand vous
quand vous évoquez le fait que la
directrice générale de la RS a été
retenue pendant une journée entière
parce que effectivement il y a un urgent
on narrivait pas à trouver un urgentiste
pour l'hôpital de carré il se trouve que
jusqu'à nouvel ordre c'est très
difficile de forcer quelqu'un à faire
quelque chose qu'il ne veut pas donc oui
l'hôpital de carré n'était pas fermé le
service d'urgence n'était pas fermé il
était régulé et nous avons trouvé
pendant quelques jours un médecin
militaire qui est venu renforcer mais
nous devons aussi être extrêmement
transparent sur la situation transparent
sur la situation et moi je pense les
élus locaux je mets pas en contradiction
les élus locaux et les parlementaires et
les représentants de la nation mais les
élus locaux cette année ils ont
considéré qu'ils avaient ce ceux avec
qui je parle et peut-être a un BIA de
discussion j'en conviens mais les élus
locaux ont considéré que ça avait été
mieux anticipé avec un degré de
difficulté qui reste majeur et je vous
le dis ici de manière très transparente
on a connu un été difficile on va
connaître un automne mais vous n'allez
pas me démentir qui va être qui va être
aussi extrêmement difficile mais non il
n'y a pas d'effondrement du système soin
monsieur le député d'aréville quand
quand vous quand vous parlez d'une
privatisation du système nous sommes le
pays au monde où l'assurance maladie
obligatoire prend en charge 80,2 % de la
consommation de soins vous ajoutez 12,6
% de la de la de la de la de la de la
par les complémentaires nous sommes le
pays au monde où la socialisation de la
dépense de santé est la plus élevée donc
a une légère marge avant le basculement
dans de quelque chose que vous décrivez
monsieur le député Gedge non la réforme
de la T2A qui est dans cette dans ce
PLFSS n'est pas une mesurette vous êtes
trop fin sur ces sujets pour mesurer que
ce que nous prévoyons et et notamment le
le le le changement y compris par
rapport à ce qui avait pu être annoncé
c'est qu'on ne se fixe pas un objectif
de de de de bouquer en disant il faut la
T2A à tel pourcentage partout la
dotation santé publique partout à tel
pourcentage c'est qu'on dit qu'il y a
des établissements un établissement une
une clinique chirurgicale qui ne fait
que des actes très processés elle sera
financée essentiellement à la T2A un CHU
il sera financé à la T2A mais aussi
largement par la dotation sur le recours
et un hôpital de proximité il aura des
responsabilités de santé de santé
publique je suis d'accord avec vous sur
je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous ont
évoqué un chantier implicitement ou
nécessairement mais qui est qui est qui
est qui est devant nous qui est celui de
du mode de financement et de et de mod
is aation des dépenses de prévention je
pense qu'on est en retard sur le fait de
savoir combien nous rapporte d'une
certaine manière le fait d'investir dans
la prévention je pense que c'est un
chantier qui est qui est devant nous on
doit arriver à construire quelque chose
là-dessus parce que à la différence il y
a quelques années on n'est pas sur des
chantiers qui sont enfin une partie
d'entre eux et je remercie ceux qui
l'ont souligné par exemple la
vaccination HPV c'est un investissement
à 20 ou 30 ans le le le l'immunisation
par par le bfortu c'est un
investissement à deux ou 3 mois donc on
doit pouvoir avoir une approche du
financement de la prévention le député
ner et ce coup-ci je vais essayer de
bien le prononcer je vous prie de
m'excuser pour la fois précédente la
l'AV la la la la la évoquer aussi le
vous avez évoqué à plusieurs reprises le
plusieurs d'entre vous
oui je souhaite que nous ouvrions et que
nous réouvrions avec les médecins des
négociations
conventionnelles dans les prochaines
semaine j'adresserai dans les prochains
jours au directeur général de la Caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie une lettre
de cadrage pour poser les principes qui
V qui vont être plus resserrés sans
doute un peu plus politique moins
nombreux que ceux qu' avaient été
précédemment mais par ailleurs ne
donnons pas le sentiment je sais pas qui
a évoqué le fait que peut-être vous que
certaines professions n'avaient pas été
réévalué depuis 2004 il y a eu cette
année 8 accords ou 2014 pardon je
décidément PRME avec les chiffres de de
H accords accords conventionnels 8
accords conventionnels qui ont été
signés avec des professions
paramédicales et donc il y a une vraie
dynamique paramédicale j'entends sur
beaucoup de bancs et je vous dis deux
choses très clairement sur sur Sport
Santé
euh je pense que on a des mesures dans
en dans le PLFSS de généralisation de
dispositifs qui avaient été expérimenté
au titre de l'article 51 j'endant qu'il
y a des demandes d'aller plus loin je
suis tout à fait prêt à ce qu'on y
travaille euh notamment sur certaines
pathologies c'est un sujet sur lequel il
faut je pense qu'il faut y travailler de
manière très transparente entre nous
dans les dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent parce que évidemment c'est
un sujet qui qui qui est évidemment très
onéreux très rapidement mais je suis
tout à fait prêt à ce qu'on l'ouvre et
enfin à ce qu'on l'ouvre et à ce qu'on
aboutisse là-dessus vous avez raison
c'est ça a été notamment évoqué très
très largement sur le sujet de la de la
santé mentale et beaucoup d'entre vous
beaucoup d'entre vous il sont revenus et
je pense notamment à à Nicolas
turquois
euh je pense que ce sujet il est
aujourd'hui j'allais dire systémique je
sais pas que le mot paraît un peu techno
dans notre société on le retrouve
partout on le retrouve dans les arrêts
maladies dans le rapport au travail dans
la vie quotidienne et dans l'impact et
dans l'impact sur le système de santé
mais sur le système de santé pas que sur
la psie enfin parce que on est dans un
secteur où je pense qu'il faut l'aborder
par la situation de l'APSI et vous avez
raison de dire et certains d'entre vous
l'ont dit ça a été pendant très
longtemps le parent pauvre de
l'hospitalisation fait une parenthèse de
2 secondes ça n'est pas financé par la
T2A il se trouve cependant que c'est une
c'est en très grande difficulté
évidemment je souhaite notamment dans la
négociation conventionnelle prendre ce
sujet notamment dans les spécialités la
PSI est une spécialité qui est
aujourd'hui sous euh euh sous la la qui
n'est pas suffisamment rémunéré euh et
je crois que ce sujet de la santé
mentale j'ai été très frappé dans tous
les entretiens notamment y compris en
quelques mois il s'est beaucoup élargi
les élus locaux les élus mais vous devez
le vivre dans tous vos dans toutes vos
circonscriptions parce que les
agressions de soignant cet été aux
urgences a été beaucoup de la
décompensation PS l'errance sur l'espace
public la difficulté à trouver et en
même temps il y a des mesures C Isac CIB
n'est pas là mais est parti 70000
secouristes psy qui ont été formés
l'expérimentation que je souhaite
généraliser des régulateurs SAMU
infirmierers psy qui donneent des
résultats vraiment remarquables au
moment du risque de passage à l'acte
donc moi je vous le dis très simplement
je considère que nous n'avons pas
embarqué toutes les mesures parce que
nous n'avons pas fini collectivement je
je nous mets tous dans la même barque
pardonz-moi vous de le dire le
diagnostic sur ce qui se passe dans la
population française et dans ce spectre
là il y a un sujet particulier santé
mentale santé mentale des enfants et
celle-ci pour le coup il y a eu des
Assises des travaux il y aura des
réponses qui seront apportées dans dans
dans les prochains jours je je je
rejette l'idée que le le notamment les
dispositifs mon soutien psio tout ça
sont des échecs ils sont très largement
utilisés notre difficulté est de trouver
des professionnels pour être euh
derrière euh au bout du fil sur la
pluriannualité le le ministre kaznav a
répondu euh et je pense que toute une
part de la pluriannualité elle est aussi
liée au sujet que que j'aiévoqué à
l'instant sur la sur la prévention je
vais aller très rapidement maintenant
j'ai dit j'avais dit à à Stéphanie ris
je le redis à à la députée Laurence
Christol oui pour ouvrir euh sur le
chantier de la
radiothérapie madame madame Mélin vous
avez évoqué à juste titre ce qui nous
préoccupe tous c'est-à-dire les éléments
sur la la néonate et la et la voilà je
je vous je je livre les choses de
manière extrêmement directe et
transparente aujourd'hui en terme
d'analyse épidémiologique de ce qui se
passe en matière de néonatologie euh il
y a effectivement la société française
de néonat qui a fait qui a qui a produit
des éléments
moi je les prends tout à fait pour ceux
qui sont c'est-à-dire
préoccupant j'ai demandé à la direction
générale de la santé avec les équipes et
notamment les remarquables équipes qui
sont les réseaux régionaux de périnat de
travailler pour essayer de comprendre
quels sont les déterminants de ça il un
déterminant évident le premier qui est
toujours la précarité qui est
extrêmement fort mais vous avez aussi
cité l'âge des primos parturiantes on a
vous n'avez pas cité mais c'est un des
sujets aussi le fait que les progrès euh
font que quelquefois on arrive à à ce
que soit mise au monde des enfants qui
sont encore plus fragiles donc mais en
même temps il faut qu'on voit si on a
ces dynamiques dans les autres pays qui
sont à peu près au même niveau que nous
et qu'on est là-dessus euh une action
derrière résolue Aurore berger est aussi
totalement engagé je prends l'engagement
ici euh y compris autant que vous le
souhaiterez madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés de
revenir quand ce travail sera fait
devant vous y compris proposer les
mesures qu'on est capable de de
construire pour ça euh je je sais
notamment qu'en matière de de de de
prise en compte des des des inégalités
social de santé il y a des choses qui
ont été faites notamment en
Île-de-France qui avait fait baisser la
mortalité infantile voir si on doit les
développer les déployer on a par
ailleurs toute une enfin on a certaines
certaines mesures là-dessus
je je voudrais
juste rajouter deux trois
points oui Mo moi mon combat mon seul
mon combat pour l'hôpital public c'est
la réouverture des lits c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour longame parce que ça
fait de l'activité mais je je vais être
très clair le
aujourd'hui ceux qui désespèrent le plus
aujourd'hui des soignants c'est de pas
être assez nombreux pour prendre des
gens c'est d'avoir des blocs FA mais
c'est ça qui est le plus désespérant ça
je pense qu'une bonne partie des sujets
financiers ils ont été non pas réglé
parce qu'ils peuvent être toujours
ouverts la question aujourd'hui elle est
celle de la de la des perspectives
professionnelles vous le voyez vous
l'entendez dans les quand vous
rencontrez des soignants qu'est-ce qu'on
fait comment on peut évoluer comment on
peut devenir infirmière de pratique
avancée comment on peut changer de job
c'est les mêmes questions que dans le
reste de la société c'est tout c'est pas
parce qu'on est médecin qu'on va faire
40 ant praticien hospitalier donc on
veut avoir des perspectives
professionnelles certains deviennent
députés même donc donc ça veut dire à
quel point il devait être au bout du
rouleau donc du coup je je
je je je ça va je CIT une boutade pour
pour que la rapporteur générale me me me
voilà donc donc on est sur cette
situation et vous on est sur cette
situation dans lesquelles on doit aller
plus loin vous avez tout à fait raison
mais je je n'allais je n'allais pas
l'oublier voilà sur juste sur je je je
je vais venir euh aux franchises vous
avez raison coproduction avec les
parlementaires moi j'ai entendu
notamment dans ces dans ces comptes de
Ségure que vous avez rapidement balayé
monsieur le déput monsieur le député
Gedge j'ai entendu plusieurs sujet
notamment la la santé mentale même si on
n'est pas aujourd'hui je vous dis on n'a
pas de mesure euh miraculeuse j'ai
entendu le député Clouet euh évoquer la
question du remboursement des
médicaments à très faible intérêt
médical je je voilà je je suis tout prêt
à ouvrir ce chantier
euh pour le PLFSS prochain et dans des
modalités voilà je pense que ce que
porte euh Stéphanie euh euh ou Laurence
sur euh euh le fait de passer sur des
forfaits sur certaines sur ce Rao thapie
éventuellement dialyse et cetera c'est
un chantier aussi qui mérite qui mérite
qu'on y travaille même si on peut lancer
assez vite donc moi je n'ai je n'ai pas
de problème aujourd'hui enfin B pour
pour finir sur ce sur ce beau sujet donc
sur les si je je je reviens un instant
sur ça aujourd'hui on a donc en
construction 3 milliards et demi
d'économie sur la sur la sur la sur le
tendantiel je je je peux pas être
soupçonné j'étais arrivé depuis quelques
jours j'ai évoqué le sujet des
franchises je l'ai évoqué tout de suite
avec des conditions j'ai dit si ce sujet
on avance on avancera
pas si en touchant au plafond de ces
franchises voilà
aujourd'hui Monsieur le enfin les uns et
les autres vous l'avez évoqué vous avez
raison euh moi je dois dire très
clairement qu'on a une partie de ces
économies qui sont comme d'habitude
avant un plfs
documenté une partie d'entre elles qui
nécessite notamment sur les soins de
ville une évolution et euh et des
pratiques professionnelles qui vont être
au cœur de la négociation
conventionnelle le sujet des franchises
moi je je je suis un peu un peu un peu
bas de plafond mais je je l'assume euh
il y a un débat parlementaire qui va se
nouer y compris très vite sur la parce
que ça sera dans la partie ça serait
dans la partie recette euh moi moi je je
souhaite que ce débat même si ce sont
des mesures de nature règlementaire
comme vous l'avez dit mais on aura ce
débat dans la partie
recette sachant que c'est là que les les
les choses vont de front on a aussi le
débat sur les FSS les sujets pouvoirs
d'achat moi je les prends en compte je
les prends en compte on vit pas dans un
monde clos donc on aura ce débat lors de
la séance à ce stade le donc le les
éléments franchises c'est si à la fin
cette mesure était retenue et je ne je
ne je n'ai pas de je ne je je ne vous
annonce pas aujourd'hui qu'elle est
retenue elle ne serait retenue sans
toucher au plafond et sans ouvrir de
nouvelles franchises il y a pas
d'article en L comme vous l'avez vu qui
permettrait qui ouvrirait de nouvelles
franchises par exemple sur les
dispositifs médicaux
voilà et ben le le tout tout dépend et
là c'est le tout dépend du moment où
cette mesure est mise en œuvre une
mesure de doublement des franchises avec
un plafond maintenu elle aurait un
rendement théorique annuel de 800
millions d'euros euh voilà et mais
aujourd'hui et je je souhaite que ce
débat on l' pardon on est aussi dans
l'hémicycle y compris après que vous
aurez commencé à débattre du PLF avec
beaucoup d'autres sujets voilà je
jusqu'à présent la partie recette euh
est évoqué voilà et donc je souhaite
qu'on ait ce débat dans l'émicyle oui je
le je le je le redis euh je j'en finis
26 ans 26 ans sur les
protections Sébastien payitaville évoqué
les bénéficiaires de la C2S je précise
juste il ont taxé au-delà de 26 ans est
pris en charge toute la vie et enfin
toute la vie tout au long tant qu'ils
sont bénéficiaires de la de la C2S
et dernier
point je n'ai pas lancé de chasse aux
arrêts maladies je suis confus si vous
me direz où vous trouvez dans la pl la
FSS la chasse aux arrêt maladies et sur
un tout petit point la téléconsultation
je sais pas si c'est le député
d'aréville ou vous pardon j'ai oublié
qui a évoqué ce sujet de de l'accès si
c'est vous sur les
téléconsultations si l'article est
précise si vous n'avez pas trouver de
médecin pour vous prescrire uneé une un
arrêt maladie vous pouvez l'avoir par
téléconsultation euh c'est c'est un
point qui a été vu mais je ne pense pas
par ailleurs que le que le que le modèle
de la téléconsultation et des des
centres de soins non programmé comme
soit le modèle le plus vertueux qui soit
pardon d'avoir été long sur ces réponses
oui alors pour vous répondre par bloc
deux questions sur la question de la
solidarité à la source qui est bien en
effet Monsieur le Député turquois un
enjeu majeur de transformation et pas
uniquement de simplification évidemment
vous l'avez vu il y a le montant net
social qui a commencé à à exister sur
les feuilles de paye l'idée c'est de
généraliser le montant n sociale à
partir de janvier de cette année janvier
2024 ce qui permet ensuite d'avoir
l'expérimentation sur le préremplissage
dès cet été et ensuite sa généralisation
desè janvier 25 mais vous le savez ça va
au-delà du préremplissage notre objectif
sur la solidarité à la source c'est de
lutter contre les indus de lutter contre
les abus il y a vraiment les deux
objectifs lutter contre le non recours
et lutter contre la fraude pour garantir
le juste droit à chacun et surtout faire
en sorte qu'il y a un gain au retour à
l'emploi et en finir un peu avec la
phrase qu'on entend trop souvent qui est
je n'ai pas intérêt à reprendre une
activité parce que j'y perdrais parce
que le corolaire ce serait une baisse de
tel ou telle aide c'est évidemment ça
l'objectif majeur de la solidarité à la
source sur les questions dépendan
beaucoup de questions sur ces sujetsl
sur la la branche autonomie il y a quand
même une vraie bascule qui s'opère à
partir du PLFSS 24 sur la branche
autonomie avec encore une fois la
fraction de CSG qui est associée avec
une montée en puissance qui est très
clair en terme budgétaire et j'ai dit
qu'en parallèle j'étais prête à avoir
bah il y a un excès exédent mais enfin
il y a un excédent jusqu'en 2027 donc en
fait si on consomme tout l'excédent bah
on va vite être en déficit donc on peut
enfin il y a une manière aussi à un
moment d'essayer de raisonner de manière
un petit peu globale et pas de raisonner
juste en année vous êtes les premiers à
nous dire que vous voulez du pluriannuel
bah là typiquement oui c'est aussi du
pluriannuel que de garantir en effet que
l'excédent soit pas intégralement
consommé pour qu'ensuite on soit en
déficit donc
l'objectif merci l'objectif c'est
évidemment de garantir l'efficacité de
cette brancheautonomie et donc le
corollaire c'est ce que j'ai annoncé au
conseil d'administration de la CNSA
c'est d'assumer une refondte des fonds
de concours pour garantir plus de
lisibilité sur le fond de concours plus
de vision aussi c'est-à-dire qu'on
assume non seulement le virage
domiciliaire qu'on assume d'avoir des
épades qui seront sans doute des lieux
beaucoup plus médicalisés notamment sur
la question des maladies
neurodégénérative mais donc qu'on est
entre deux tout un une logique
intermédiaire d'habitat intermédiaire de
résidence autonomie de résidence senior
qui à ce stade ne sont pas soutenu
financé par la CNSA de manière
extrêmement marginale et là on a un vrai
bon en avant qu'on doit pouvoir faire
ensemble sur la question de la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle justement
déjà moi je suis heureuse encore une
fois que tout le monde finalement se
félicite que cette proposition de loit
bien vieillir et bien revienne sur le
devant de la scène à partir du 20
novembre parce qu'on montre bien qu'elle
n'est pas totalement inutile et qu'elle
permet d'accélérer sur les circuits de
signalement sur la lutte contre la
maltraitance sur la reconnaissance des
aides à domicile sur la carte
professionnelle sur la transparence sur
les indicateurs bref il y a des avancées
qui sont très concrètes au-delà de
celles qui ont été ajoutées par les
parlementaires déjà j'attends qu'on ait
finalisé l'examen et j'espère donc que
ceux qui ont soutenu un certain nombre
de ces amendements viendront voter la
loi définitive ou alors il y a une forme
quand même d'incohérence de se dire
qu'on soutient tous les ajouts mais
qu'on soutiendrait pas la loi la loi
définitive ensuite ensuite mais je déjà
en fait j'ai pas à répondre monsieur le
député à vos injonctions en fait non
j'ai à répondre à vos questions ce qui
est pas exactement la même chose donc je
réponds à vos questions et c'est quand
même moi qui je fais qui choisit mes
réponses euh voilà vous êtes libre de
vos questions je suis libre de mes
réponses quand même donc ce que je dis
sur la réponse et je l'ai toujours dit
depuis ma nomination c'est que mon enjeu
n'était pas d'avoir une loi qui porte
mon nom mais de savoir quels étaient les
éléments efficaces et les éléments
efficaces est-ce que c'est une loi de
programmation pluri-annuelle est-ce que
c'est un protocole pluri-annuel ce que
j'ai évoqué monsieur le député hier soir
mais vous n'étiez pas là quand on a
parlé justement du PLF et des des
missions solidarité ben je suis désolé
mais l'enjeu c'est l'efficacité est-ce
que c'est des accroches législatives
dont on a besoin parce qu'il faudrait
aller au-delà de ce que va permettre la
loi bien vieillli de ce que peut
permettre demain la réforme des fonds de
concours de la CNSA de ce que peut
permettre la branche autonomie ou pas et
moi pour l'instant la démonstration elle
a pas été faite de se dire que il
fallait par principe qui est forcément
une loi nouvelle ce que je veux c'est
garantir des moyens en logique
pluriannuel ce que je veux c'est
garantir la montée en puissance de la
branche autonomie et ce que je veux
c'est faire la réforme des fonds de
concours de la CNSA et travailler dans
une logique de coopération notamment
avec les département dont on sait qu'on
a des compétences qui sont quand même
partagées donc la montée en puissance
elle doit aussi être partagée sur la
question de la montée en puissance sur
le nombre de postes notamment les 50000
postes d'ici 2030 il y a eu donc cette
cette budgétisation l'année dernière qui
a été garantie ces 150 millions d'euros
qui ont déjà été consommés pour garantir
les 3000 postes de l'an dernier donc on
vous donnera évidemment le bilan précis
dès la fin de l'année il reste encore
des recrutements en cours on est au mois
d'octobre donc on va pouvoir encore
continuer et on double quand même cet
effort puisqu'on passe de 3000 à 6000
soignants pour l'année prochaine donc ça
veut dire qu'on garantit que les moyens
ils sont accordés dans ce PLFSS pour
qu'encore une fois on ait cette
trajectoire mais vous l'avez dit
vous-même il suffit pas d'inscrire des
moyens en PLFSS pour garantir que les
recrutements soient faits c'est un enjeu
général d'attractivité des métiers du
soin que ce soit sur le sanitaire ou sur
le champ médico-social sur lesquels on
travaille d'où les enjeux évidemment de
revalorisation d'où ce qu'on a annoncé
conjointement avec le ministre de la
Santé sur la revalorisation travail de
nuit jour Ferrier et weekend en
particulier sur la question des aénans
question de de Laurence Cristol
notamment sur ce qui est appelé le
baluchonnage ou manière plus large le
relayage moi je suis très favorable à ce
qu'on puisse poursuivre une
expérimentation qui pour moi a largement
fait ses preuves la question c'est
plutôt de savoir là quel est le bon
véhicule est-ce que ou pas c'est
possible en PLFSS ou à défaut on a en
effet un véhicule qui s'appelle la PPL
bien vieillir qui permettrait de
garantir que cette expérimentation se
poursuive parce qu'elle répond à des
besoins essentiels des personnes parce
que pour beaucoup de personnes qui sont
accompagnées quitter leur domicile est
en fait trop brutal elles ne peuvent pas
n pas les la la volonté la capacité à
quitter leur domicile mais leurs
familles pour autant ont besoin de répi
et donc le fait justement d'avoir ce
relayage à domicile est une solution de
répis qui à mon sens correspond à de
nombreuses situations des personnes
directement concernées et de leur
famille sur la question des familles
encore une foisi moi j'assume
complètement de se dire qu'il faut
prendre un vrai virage qui est que la
politique familiale doit d'abord être
une politique universelle au service de
toutes les familles et donc en soutien à
la natalité ce qui veut dire que sur
toutes les réformes que que nous
engageons et que nous allons engager je
pense par exemple la question du reste à
charge pour les familles la question du
complément mode de garde l'idée n'est
pas de faire en sorte d'exclure un
certain nombre de familles ou de choisir
à la place des parents les solutions
qu'ils ont pour leurs enfants les
parents font en général ce qu'ils
peuvent c'était quand même une
incohérence majeure de se dire que les
parents avaient un reste à charge plus
élevé quand ils avaient recours à des
assistantes maternelles que quand ils
avaient recours à un accueil collectif
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de se dire
que sur toutes les mesures que nous
mettons en œuvre elles doivent être
universelles j'ai pas de tabou sil faut
revenir sur un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été prises précédemment la
question elle est surtout question
budgétaire vous le savez bien mais en
tout cas politiquement j'ai aucun tabou
là-dessus au contraire parce que je
pense que c'est un des facteurs qui a
conduit et c'est documenté depuis 2011 à
la baisse de la natalité et donc oui il
y a bien un lien direct entre la
politique familiale que l'on mène les
freins objectifs au fait de pouvoir
avoir des enfants au-delà d'en jeu de
santé publique qu'on veut adresser
notamment sur les question d'infertilité
et le nombre d'enfants que nous pouvons
accueillir sur la question du postpartum
c'est quand on a créé la question des
1000 premiers jours de la vie de
l'enfant c'est la premier jour de la vie
de l'enfant mais c'est aussi évidemment
la question de la mère c'est pas
uniquement évidemment l'enfant qu'on
prend en charge c'est comment on
accompagne mieux soit la future mère
soit la mère c'est notamment l'entretien
post-natal précoce qui permet de déceler
vous voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui on a un
parcours qui n'existait pas il y a
quelques années au bénéfice des futurs
parents moi je pense que dans une
logique d'ailleurs de responsabilisation
des deux parents il faudrait qu'il y a
un vrai parcours qui soit proposé aux
deux parents et pas uniquement à la mère
sur la question de la prévention des
nouveaux risques sur la sédentarité sur
les enjeux des écrans par exemple et je
pense que ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut réussir à travailler ensemble sur
les sujets évidemment néonath que vous
avez abordé même réponse que ministre de
la santé c'est une priorité évidemment
absolue donc encore une fois il faut
maintenant qu'on documente de manière
très précise pour comprendre ce qui se
passe et pour évidemment prendre les
bonnes décisions parce que c'est c'est
un fait qui ne peut laisser personne je
l'espère indifférent et qui en tout cas
suppose qu'il y a une alliance de nous
tous pour évidemment qu'on puisse régler
cet enjeu qui est absolument majeur et
là encore sur les enjeux de natalité je
crois que ça devrait être l'un des
premiers objectifs politique que nous
devrions avoir collectivement parce
qu'un pays qui voit une baisse de sa
natalité ça dit quelque chose quand même
sur l'état de notre pays ça dit quelque
chose sur le décrochage entre le désir
d'enfant et le nombre d'enfants que nous
réussissons à avoir et donc l' c'est
bien de laisser un libre choix aux
familles de respecter leur choix
d'accompagner les familles de les
soutenir et je crois que là-dessus en
tout cas je l'espère on peut avoir des
alliances parlementaires je vous
remercie merci pardon monsieur vous
voulez juste un petit mot de
complément voilà non pardon j'ai j'ai
j'ai tout à l'heure eu je je pris de ma
excusé dans l'échange avec Pierre
daréville je voudrais être plus précis
je je je voulais dire d'une part que je
ne considère pas que le le loup soit
dans la bergerie en matière de de de de
socialisation de la dépense de santé
mais par contre vous avez raison et
j'aurais dû rebondir vous n'avez pas
employé le mot privatisation mais
marchandisation donc je vous en donne
acte et je vous prie d'excuser cette
voilà non mais par contre je je pense
qu'on a un sujet mais qui renvoie je
voulais en dire un mot à ce
que Madame Rist ou madame l' on évoqué
c'est que on a quand même des mouvements
de fond dans le secteur de la santé qui
sont des mouvements de
financiarisation euh que une partie
d'entre eux on ne les a pas vu venir je
pense par exemple à la biologie médicale
euh où certains à postériori disent
qu'il les avaient vraiment vu venir mais
on les a on les a vu venir ils étaient
déjà bien bien lancés et donc moi je
souhaite je pense que ce sujet de la
financierisation est
central parce que derrière ce ce sont
les
interlocuteurs qu'on a au quotidien pour
faire la santé moi si je je l'ai dit je
l'ai déjà évoqué et je suis très très
ouvert là-dessus ça fait partie des
sujets où on peut travailler au long
cours je pense que si c'est une mission
parlementaire ou quelque chose comme ça
qui peut traiter notamment de ce sujet
par exemple je le dis en radiologie
aujourd'hui enfin c'est pas des médecin
que je vais le dire je pense qu'on
avance à une allure phénoménale vers une
une la prise de contrôle de de la
radiologie voilà on a ce sujet et on a
ce sujet pour ça que je fais référence
Laurence c'est Stéphanie c'est que les
endroits où euh on a des des tarifs qui
sont sans doute plus élevés que le coût
mais c'est là où les acteurs privés se
jettent pour aller dessus se confè par
exemple la la radiothérapie voilà et
puis on a des modèles euh une partie
d'entre eux qui ont été évoqués
travaillés ici je pense par exemple à
euh au centre de soin non programmé
Fadila il y avait travaillé en partie
mais pas que donc moi sur ce sujet de la
financiarisation euh du secteur que se
passe-t-il est-ce qu'il se passe des
choses structurelles dans la pharmacie
ou pas de la pharmacie d'officine
j'entends je je ne le sais pas et ça
renvoie et c'est pour ça que je je
répondais à Pierre d'Ille sur ça ça
renvoie derrière aussi au prix du MOC et
cetera parce que s'il y a de la
financiarisation massive ou de
rroupement capitalistique dans la
pharmacie ça veut dire qu'il y a des
sujets de marge arrière ça veut dire
qu'il y a peut-être des économies à
faire là-dessus et cetera et cetera donc
moi je suis très je le dis trèst je
pense que c'est un sujet majeur je pense
que ça mérite que le
Parlement se accompagné par toutes les
tous les moyens possibles d'inspection
et cetera regarde ce qui se passe sur ce
sujet et en tout cas moi c'est un sujet
que je souhaite traiter euh pour faire
la cartographie de ce qui se passe
pardon mais je je voulais répondre un
peu plus précisément merci Madame et
Monsieur le Ministre